bonjour à tous Dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre deux auditions
menées par la mission commune
d'information sur les rythmes scolaires
mission commune d'information qui
rassemble donc toutes les tendances
politiques même si à l'origine il s'agit
d'une demande de l'UMP objectif de cette
mission évaluer la mise en place de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires cette
réforme décidée par Vincent payon qui
est facultative en septembre 2013 mais
qui va devenir obligatoire à partir de
septembre 2014 euh les membres de cette
mission d'information ont mené de
nombreuses auditions depuis 3 semaines
ils ont auditionné le comité de pilotage
de la Conférence nationale des rythmes
scolaires ils ont auditionné la
Direction Générale de l'Enseignement
également des pédopsychiatres pour
évaluer si cette réforme est bonne pour
les enfants place ce matin et bien aux
familles avec d'abord l'Union nationale
des associations
familiales bien mes chers collègues si
vous en êtes d'accord nous allons
débuter cette nouvelle audition euh
organisée dans le cadre de notre mission
commune d'information sur les rythmes
scolaires afin que nous puissions de
façon avisée déposer des propositions et
des conclusions tant
attendus sur ce sur ce sujet-là
aujourd'hui donc merci merci Monsieur
Rémi Guyot vice-président de l'Union
nationale des associations familiales
merci également à Madame Patricia hum
coordinatrice qui sont avec nous
aujourd'hui pour nous expliquer un petit
peu le positionnement de l'UNAF dans le
cadre de cette de cette réforme je vous
propose une première intervention une
présentation de votre part suivie
ensuite de questionnements de la part de
Madame la rapporteur à la au
questionnement auquel vous pourrez
répondre immédiatement et ensuite nous
prendrons les questions de nos collègues
qui seront présents voilà à vous
monsieur guot merci madame la Présidente
merci Madame la rapporteur ben oui tout
merci d'avoir effectivement invité
l'UNAF à s'exprimer sur ce sujet des
rythmes scolaires et je voudrais bien
évidemment vous transmettre le salut de
notre président François frondard qui
est retenu cet après-midi au Conseil
économique et social donc je tenterai de
de le représenter sur cette question qui
concerne effectivement le département
éducationjeunesse à l'UNAF dont j'ai
davantage la charge avec madame omouan
qui
m'accompagne notre positionnement bien
évidemment en tant qu'unaf il est je
dirais complémentaire c'est un autre
regard que celui porté par les
associations de parents d'élèves par
exemple qui sont directement concernés
en tant qu'usager nous nous avons sans
doute un regard plus global de des
familles je dirais avec avec les
différentes générations concernées
l'UNAF bien sûr dans sa mission de
donner avis sur les questions qui
touchent la famille s'appuie aussi sur
un réseau hein bien sûr le réseau des
100udaf composé elle-même
d'associations donc et de mouvement qui
présentent une grande diversité et et un
pluralisme mais qui sont en même temps
je dirais des lieux d'observation hein
des lieux d'action d'implication et
propositions sur les
territoire sur le sujet qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui c'est bien en en
s'appuyant sur ces observations euh
puisque l'UNAF en deux chiffres regroupe
aujourd'hui
7500 associations dans une grande
diversité d'approche hein des questions
qui touchent la famille mais c'est aussi
700000 familles adérente à travers à
travers ces associations alors bien
évidemment au-delà de la réflexion que
peut conduire aussi le conseil
d'administration de l'institution donc
UNAF c'est bien sûr en intégrant toutes
ces observations de terrain que nous
tenterons de vous faire partager
quelques réflexions sur le sujet si vous
voulez nous d'embler
l'UNAF est-ce que parasite j'espère que
ça vous gne pas non non non non non je
ça il y a un peu de renvoi mais bon
c'est pas c'est c'est pas
dramatiqueésolé non non mais c'est c'est
pas oui si vous voulez par rapport à
cette question sur les ritthes spolire
je voudrais d'abord si vous voulez les
les resituer dans un ensemble parce que
l'UNAF c'est d'emblé je dirais intéressé
euh dès dès la conférence nationale sur
les rythmes scolaires hein donc avec le
ministre Luc Chatel on sait aussi bien
sûr d'emblé inscrit dans la réflexion et
la concertation sur la refondation de
l'école on a a participé à de grand
nombre à un grand nombre de groupes de
travail on a produit aussi un certain
nombre de de contributions dans dans ce
cadre- làà et pourquoi si vous voulez
l'UNAF c'est'est d'emblé investi aussi
sur ces questions bien parce que d'une
part pour nous ce qui est fondamental
bien évidemment c'est l'intérêt de
l'enfant hein parce que je crois que si
cette proposition si cette loi si ce
décret sur les rythmes à à un sens
profond c'est bien sans doute celui de
l'intérêt de l'enfant et pour pour nous
ce qui est fondamental bien c'est de
permettre à chaque jeune de de de se
positionner dans un parcours de réussite
et d'aller au bout de son projet je
crois que ça pour nous c'est tout à fait
fondamental bien évidemment ça nous
amène tout de suite à évoquer toutes les
questions qu'il y a autour du décrochage
scolair autour de la nécessité d'assurer
un certain nombre de fondamentaux de
mieux coordonner peut-être les relations
entre les différentes étapes d'un
parcours de formation entre le primaire
et le collège le collège et le lycée le
lycée l'enseignement supérieur c'est
toutes les questions qui tournent autour
de l'orientation donc voyez c'est bien
en en app en abordant et en ayant à
l'esprit l'ensemble de ces éléments que
l'UNAF s'est investi sur cette question
alors plus spécialement sur les rythmes
scolaires euh c'est avec un une certaine
prudence bien évidemment que nous nous
exprimons aujourd'hui pourquoi bah parce
que effectivement on a des remontées de
terrain on a des positionnements
d'experts on a notre réflexion interne
mais cela porte disons-le malgré tout
sur un nombre limité de lieux puisque
bon je ne vais pas vous assiner les
chiffres que vous connaissez mieux que
moi et que vous avez l'occasion de de
d'interpréter et d'analyser sur d'autres
d'autres intervenants à partir des des
prestations de d'autres intervenants
mais bon aujourd'hui c'est en gros 4000
écoles demain ça peut être plus de 20000
voire 24000 je crois que c'est 24000
communes qui ont une école donc bien
évidemment les observations et et les
remontées que nous pouvons avoir
aujourd'hui elles s'inscrivent dans
cette dans ce contexte un un peu limité
je m'arrêterai sur trois points d'abord
quelques réflexions générales sur les
rythmes scolaire plus spécifiquement
puisque bon j'ai évoqué la loi de
programmation et sur la refondation de
l'école mais bon aujourd'hui on est plus
centré sur les rythmes donc quelques
réflexions générales sur les rythmes
ensuite peut-être à partir des remontées
de terrain que nous avons et bien quelle
perception aujourd'hui et quel vécu nous
exprime un certain nombre de familles à
travers les associations qui qui
composent effectivement l'UNAF et les
UDAF et puis je terminerai avec quelques
pistes bah de
préconisation de propositions j'ose pas
dire de recommandations mais quelques
pistes qui nous paraissent important
alors tout d'abord sur les les les
réflexions générales bah pour nous
effectivement au niveau de de l'Union
nationale des associations familiales il
y a des éléments tout à fait
intéressants et positifs ben d'abord
c'est des journées moins longues hein au
plan de l'enseignement tout au moins
hein c'est aussi et c'est important euh
la possibilité pour un grand nombre
d'enfants qui n'y avaient peut-être pas
accès précédemment euh la découverte
d'activités diverses qui peuvent être
d'ordre culturel artistique sportive
éventuellement et et qui permettront
peut-être à des enfants bien de de
s'impliquer et pourquoi pas de se
passionner hein pour pour telle ou telle
pour telle ou telle activité trè élément
qui nous paraît intéressant aussi c'est
que cette proposition je dirais invite
et je le j'y reviendrai dans mon propos
de conclusion parce que
invite l'ensemble des acteurs concernés
hein que ce soit les les élus bien sûr
puisque il s'agit du primaire donc des
collectivités locales commune ou
intercommunalité ou syndicat multiples
hein bon je il se trouve que je le vis
aussi à titre personnel En tant que
petit maire d'une commune rurale donc
voilà mais c'est les élus les
enseignants les parents les associations
et je dirais presque un absent c'est
c'est le monde économique alors que il
est peut-être concerné j'y reviendrai
dans les dans les préconisation donc ça
invite au dialogue et à la construction
collective d'un projet ça ça nous est un
élément intéressant le le 4eme c'est
l'allègement des programmes qui pour
nous doit aller avec sinon effectivement
il y aura un problème si on diminue le
temps d'enseignement et qu'on n'allèche
pas les programmes en les recentrant
peut-être sur les fondamentaux hein je
crois que monsieur le ministre l'a
rappelé récemment mais pour nous c'est
un point importantin se recentrer
effectivement sur les les capacités de
base lire écrire compter Dieu sait si
c'est fondament
que ce soit acquis dans le primaire pour
assurer un parcours de
formation le moins chaotique possible
mais il y a aussi quand même quelques
points qui nous paraissent non traités
ou non résolus hein bon quand on évoque
la question des journées moins longues
c'est aussi toute la question de
l'organisation de l'année scolaire hein
et et c'est vrai que pour nous le le
nombre de jours de vacances bon sans
fait sans toujours euh euh cristallisé
sur euh les les les comparaisons euh
internationales mais ça n'empêche qu'on
a quand même un nombre de jours de
d'école court et un nombre de jours de
vacances important donc cette questionlà
de l'équilibre nous paraît encore à
traiter euh la question de l'alternance
aussi des temps de cours et des temps de
de vacances hein on avait beaucoup dans
le cadre des groupes de travail lors de
la concertation hein entre juillet et
octobre 2012 on avait av beaucoup évoqué
la question des des rythmes 7 semaines
d'enseignement 2 semaines de cours et
cetera mais ça pose la question des
zones ça pose la question aussi des
vacances d'été donc voilà je ne donne
pas de réponse bien évidemment c'est ce
serait bien présomptueux de le faire à
notre endroit mais c'est une question
qui nous semble rester à traiter hein
bon la prise en compte aussi des
capacités d'attention des élèves c'est
d'une autre nature hein mais quand on
écoute un certain nombre d'experts et
notamment de de médecins de pédiatre de
de de de chonobiologistes et cetera bon
tous quand même même si il peut y avoir
des variantes dans leur expression tout'
exprime quand même l'idée que le la
capacité d'attention des enfants elle
n'est pas linéaire tout au long de la
journée et que les matinées sont sans
doute plus propices à des activités qui
font appel à l'abstraction et voir un
peu l'après-midi mais sans doute plus
tard vers bon certains disent la tranche
15 17h enfin bon je je ne suis pas
spécialiste moi moi-même je mais bon on
peut s'appuyer sur ces questionsl euh il
y a bien sûr et ça j'imagine que vous
l'aurez entendu de nombreuses fois mais
c'est aussi la question de la diversité
sur les territoires hein donc
comment comment effectivement veiller à
ce que un cadre commun puisse quand même
être proposé à l'ensemble des enfants
même si moi je crois beaucoup et l'UNAF
également parce que bon quand on
s'appuie sur un tissu associatif qui est
est impliqué sur les territoires on voit
bien que tout peut tout ne peut pas se
construire de la même façon partout
l'important c'est l'implication et la
volonté de réussir quelque chose
toujours dans l'intérêt du du du de
celui qui est concerné au premier plan
c'est-à-dire l'enfant la question bien
sûr des des des financements aussi voilà
un certain nombre de points voyez bon je
vais pas trop trop allonger la liste
mais autant on voit des éléments
intéressants et positifs autant il y a
encore un certain nombre d'éléments qui
nous paraissent rester à traiter deème
volet la perception que qu'on a à
travers les les les remontées des
familles via via les UDAF donc les
unions départementales et bien sûr via
les les associations alors
je répète à nouveau quand même que c'est
sur une période courte hein et que sans
doute qu'il faudra garder cette cette
capacité à observer à analyser ce qui se
passe et et peut-être enfin en tout cas
c'est une volonté qu'on exprime
régulièrement à lunaf et euh avec la la
la volonté je dirais de de de se
remettre autour de la table si vous me
permettez cette expression et de trouver
les réponses hein dans un contexte donné
avec les acteurs concernés sur un
territoire donc pour résoudre ces
problèmes alors un premier point qui
nous remonte et je c'est pas dans
l'ordre chronologique d'importance c'est
que euh les parents évoquent de
souventin la fatigue des enfants alors
sur la fatigue des enfants c'est vrai
que il y a sans doute beaucoup à à à
s'interroger parce que et y compris en
tant que famille hein bon alors c'est
vrai on va dire le mercredi matin il
faut qu'il se les enfants se lèvent
aussi mais là on voit bien que ça pose
la question et quand on écoute notamment
on a beaucoup travaillé à lunaf avec le
un réseau de spécialistes le réseau
morphé ce sont des médecins qui sont
spécialiste du sommeil on a même à lunaf
gravé un un DVD sur le sujet qui qui est
beaucoup distribué d'ailleurs et qui est
très demandé par les familles où on voit
bien que ce qui compte c'est plus la
régularité des rythmes du coucher du
lever et cetera et que donc
là permettez-moi de le dire comme ça
mais c'est vrai que les familles ont
aussi une responsabilité quand on
regarde le temps des enfants devant les
écrans et cetera bon je pense que on a
peut-être
aussi à se à se reg regarder je dirais
et à ne pas tout porter sur cette
question mais se dire finalement si on
dit que l'intérêt de l'enfant est
premier est-ce queon n' pas aussi à
repenser un certain nombre de choses
donc les familles nous disent ça mais en
même temps je crois que ça ça nous
invite à à travailler aussi avec les
familles sur cette questionl deuxième
élément qui nous remontre régulièrement
c'est la question des classes maternelle
quand même hein bon alors là sur la
question des classes maternelles très
franchement je crois que le le nombre de
remonté est conséquent et il y a
sûrement quelque chose à imaginer
euh après ce qui ce qui ressort aussi et
ça bon je crois que ça nous renvoie à la
précaution d'usage prise en introduction
sur la durée limitée d'observation qui
est la nottre aujourd'hui c'est que bon
des parents expriment le l'idée que ils
sont pas convaincus du bien fondé hein
et et de l'impact de la réforme sur le
bien-être de l'enfant donc là je pense
qu'il y a aussi un peu de pédagogie un
peu de pédagogie à faire alors
effectivement quand on regarde ces
observations il y a quelques hypothèses
sans doute d'explication
c'est vrai que pour un grand nombre de
familles les enfants passent à peu près
le même temps à l'école même si les
activités sont sont sont diversifié
puisque bon entre 8h30 9h 8h45 et et
16h30 même si on a une gestion des temps
différentes ça n'empêche que l'enfant
est est hors de sa famille donc bon
voilà pour les parents il y a peut-être
cette idée que finalement le temps passé
à l'école elle-même alors ça pose
d'ailleurs toute la question aussi sans
doute de de de la conciliation je dirais
entre vie professionnelle et et vie
familiale bon alors bon je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure qui peut être une hypothèse
d'explication c'est que les enfants
n'ont plus le mercredi matin bon même si
je l'ai je l'ai nuancé en évoquant tout
à l'heure le le
point de de la régularité des rythmes
évoqués par un certain nombre de
spécialistes un autre élément qui nous
remontre régulièrement c'est les
difficultés d'organisation dans
certaines écoles hein et je dirais que
je l'associe aussi à la fatigue des
enfants exprimés par les parents parce
que finalement ces difficultés
d'organisation je pense que ça génère et
en tout cas c'est ce qui nous est
remonté ça génère du stress des parents
qui doivent bah retrouver aussi des
modalités d'organisation et sans doute
que ça rejaillit aussi sur la fatigue
des enfants donc bon là il y a il y a un
point la question aussi de l'équilibrein
de l'équilibre et du choix des activités
hein je crois que entre le temps de de
scolaire donc de 5h30 maximum par par
jour donc et d'une durée hebdomadaire
fixée donc par le la loi et et les
activités périscolaires les activités
pédagogiques complémentaires sans doute
que là il y a aussi un équilibre à
trouver selon les endroits parce que
est-ce que on n'est pas trop rapidement
dans l'idée qu'il faut faut remplir
absolument toutes les cases il faut
remplir tous les temps alors que
peut-être que les enfants rêvent aussi
peut-être de pouvoir rêver justement et
que on ne les voilà et et que là-dessus
je pense qu'on a aussi des questions
sans doute à se poser un autre élément
qui est souvent évoqué c'est la
diversité des encadrants hein la
diversité des encadrants euh parce que
effec et notamment dans les maternels
hein c'est vrai que bon notamment dans
les classe dans les petites et moyennes
sections hein on le voit bien si c'est
pas les assistantes maternelles qui
conduisent les les activité d
périscolaire bon on a enfin peut-être
qu'avec le temps les choses se se
règleront mais bon cette diversité
d'encadrant est un peu stressante et
sans doute pour pour les pour les
enfants alors bon voilà quelques
éléments qui nous remontent mais on a
aussi d'autres éléments hein qui nous
reviennent des des des UDAF
euh bon via les UDAF des familles c'est
que bon ça désorganise les agendas des
familles ça je l'ai déjà dit hein il y a
le problème du mercredi avec la relation
entre l'école et les activités euh bon
je j'ai encore la la la formulation
alssh c'est plus comme ça qu'on les
appelle c'est c'est les CM quelque chose
c'est onaelle plus ça alssh mais le le
vrai non non non non C LSH c'était
encore avant il y a un nouveau terme bon
mais je je il me vient pas à l'esprit
peu importe c'est la même chose c'est
c'est la LS donc la la relation entre
l'école du mercredi et pour les familles
qui avaient les enfants à à l'accueil de
loisir tout le mercredi il y a des
questions qui se posent autour de la
cantine autour de des transports et
cetera bon donc là c'est encore des des
points qui nous qui nous remontent
euh bon au niveau des activités
périscolaires euh des familles nous
disent attention euh dans dans certains
endroits ça ne peut être que de la de la
ça ça peut être spécifiquement de la
garderie et bon ça pose question en
terme de de qualité de la des
propositions faites aux enfants sur
l'ensemble des territoires une question
qui revient et qui ne vous étonnera pas
c'est autour de l'encadrement je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure par la diversité
pour les petits mais il y a aussi la
question du recrutement et de la
formation des des des encadrants hein
bon mais ça je crois que c'est un point
qui qui ressort très souvent pour les
fait famille il y a la gratuité ou pas
hein et là c'est vrai Queen terme par
rapport à l'UNAF nous on exprime
clairement que il faut qu'il y ait
gratuité pour les familles hein et puis
peut-être un autre point qui remonte
aussi dans certaines situations
c'est des situations où les activités
périscolaires sont réservées aux enfants
qui sont à la cantine ou à l'étude hein
et et que par contre les autres enfants
ne sont pas directement concernés bon je
je ne citerai pas de lieu pour garder
une forme quand même de de un respect de
des des situations qui sont aujourd'hui
encore en construction mais ça ce sont
des éléments qui nous sont remontés les
les par les familles alors troème
élément je vousoudrais pas être trop
long donc sur pour nous UNEF hein je
dirais institution familiale qui
s'exprime aussi en complémentarité avec
les associations de parents d'élèves je
l'ai dit au début et je le redis à cet
instant parce que c'est important de le
bien le recevoir comme ça euh bon
quelques préconisations ou pistes de
proposition d'abord je crois qu'il faut
si on veut faire en sorte que les
quelques éléments positifs que j'évoqué
en début de propos euh et bien
s'organise se mettre en œuvre se
développe il faut absolument qu'on crée
des situations de dialogue entre les
différents acteurs hein pour que ces
organisations à trouver soit bien une
construction collective et que on trouve
les réponses avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés hein pour toutes les questions
très pratiques autour des locaux autour
du transport autour des problèmes de
cantine autour des questions de coût
aussi donc et et bien
sûr mettre les acteurs en en
construction collective en tenant compte
des réalités locales hein je crois que
ça c'est pour nous un point vraiment
important le deuxième élément que je
voudrais souligner à cet instant c'est
et bien peut-être aussi agir pour que
les familles je dirais s'approprient
progressivement les objectifs et le sens
de la réforme hein je crois que si on
veut effec on ne fera pas réussir ce
type de nouvelle organisation hein si on
est convaincu que l'intérêt de l'enfant
est premier sans que chacun des acteurs
effectivement s'approprie s'approprie la
réforme hein donc si on veut
effectivement que ça contribue à lut
contre le décrochage que ça facilite les
apprentissages autre élément qui nous
paraît important c'est sans doute et je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure mais c'est dans
nos préconisations et c'est veiller à ne
pas tomber dans le piège de la
surconsommation et de la suractivité
hein je crois que ça c'est ça nous
paraît vraiment important hein je pense
qu'il faut aussi
que cette cette proposition redonne si
on veut vraiment alléger hein les les
rythmes et et la pression sur les
enfants en terme de d'acquisition
scolaire puisque théoriquement on
diminue le temps d'enseignement il faut
que les autres temps permettent à
l'enfant je dirais de de vivre une
certaine réalité de détente et de
décompression hein et et
d'investissement d'une autre nature que
l'appel à ses capacités d'absorption de
de de de connaissance hein donc
réapprendre à aux enfants peut-être à
gérer des temps de liberté de jeux he je
je je mettais même dans dans mes notes
de rêve hein je crois que c'est c'est
c'est important enfin bon euh c'est
toujours délicat de faire appel à ses
propres expériences mais euh bon moi qui
ne suis plus de la première jeunesse je
me souviens des temps de la petite école
primaire d'un village rural on avait des
temps où notre imagination était très
fertile parce que on construisait nos
propres jeux on avait du temps pour cela
et et je crois que c'est c'est important
aujourd'hui peut peut-être de redonner
aux enfants de libérer les enfants de
cette espèce de pression permanente où
il faut toujours faire appel à à leur à
leur attention autre point important
c'est mettre de la souplesse hein je
pense aussi et là quand je dis mettre de
la souplesse ça s'adresse aussi aux
acteurs éducation nationale hein je
pense que bon pour aussi avoir
l'occasion de de croiser au CDEN et au
CA donc les les les la hiérarchie de
l'éducation nationale dans ma propre
dans mon propre département et ma propre
région je vois bien que on s'est
peut-être un peu et bon ça n'a pas un
caractère négatif dans ma bouche mais on
s'est peut-être rapidement enfermé dans
des schémas hein euh et finalement alors
qu'il était peut-être important que tous
les acteurs se mettent dans une démarche
de construction et de réflexion on a
peut-être mis les gens dans des schémas
un peu rapidement et c'est vrai que pour
l'organisation des temps par exemple ben
il fallait sans doute que les tapes les
temps d'activités périscolaire à côté
des apaissés les activités pédagogiques
complémentaires et cetera soit à tel
moment de la journée ou à tel autre
moment alors que finalement ce qui est
important c'est que tout ça s'articule
et s'organise avec une certaine fluidité
une certaine sérénité donc sans doute
mettre un peu de
souplessein je pense que ça évitera de
tomber dans le piège de la suctivité de
la surconsommation euh parce que
effectivement pour argumenter ce ce ce
cette expression est-ce que on doit
effectivement privilégier des journées
régulières sécurisantes apaisantes pour
les enfants euh plutôt que
l'organisation d'activités
périscolaires extraordinaire qui aurait
un caractère extraordinaire hein dans
les préconisations toujours excusez-moi
d'être un peu long je je vais bientôt
arriver à ma conclusion c'est la
gratuité pour les familles hein ça pour
nous c'est c'est quand même un élément
important parce que euh on voit bien
hein dans bon les toutes les enquêtes
qui sont faites aujourd'hui tant par euh
l'éducation nationale que par euh euh
l'association des mares des maires de
France euh ou ou d'autres organisations
euh on voit bien queil y a quand même
des des différences d'une région à
l'autre d'une ville à l'autre d'une
commune à l'autre et que là-dessus
l'UNAF euh bon dit euh clairement euh
nous on souhaite on souhaite la la la
gratuité pour les familles euh bon les
classes maternelles ça fait partie des
préconisations je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure la question de de l'encadrement
hein donc la question de l'encadrement
en terme je dirais de
formation de recrutement bien sûr dans
certains endroits et peut-être aussi euh
préparer l'encadrement euh à à
accueillir euh des acteurs locaux et
notamment je pense aux acteurs
associatifs moi si vous voulez un autre
élément une autre façon de dire le le le
fond de de de la pensée de l'UNAF par
rapport à ça et et moi personnellement à
titre personnel j'en suis vraiment
convaincu c'est que c'est une occasion
aussi
euh si je m'arrête aux aspects positif
alors que j'ai listé aussi un aspect une
série d'aspects problématiques c'est que
ça peut permettre aussi d'ouvrir l'école
un peu sur son territoire et que ouvrir
l'école sur son territoire c'est
peut-être permettre aussi aux acteurs
associatifs d'y entrer alors bien
évidemment il est pas question moi je
pens nous au niveau de l'UNAF on est
très impliqué dans le dispositif Lire et
faire lire par exemple hein B qui est
maintenant quand même un dispositif
assez connu bon on a plus d'une
soixantaine d'udaf impliqué dans la
démarche au au côté de de la Ligue de
l'enseignement puisque ce sont ces deux
grands réseaux qui portent le programme
et on voit bien on avait la semaine
dernière une réunion avec un groupe de
l'cteur dans dans mon département et ce
que j'entendais c'est que ces ces
bénévoles qui sont vraiment très motivés
pour partager ce plaisir de lire avec
des enfants et en même temps créer ce
lien intergénérationnel qui est tout à
fait fondamental c'est pour ça que euh
cette ce regard sur l'école euh c'est
bien l'ensemble des générations et donc
les famille dans leur dans leur
diversité y compris dans leurs
composantes qui sont concerné et donc je
crois qu'il faut aussi que l'encadrement
de ces activités puisse à un moment ou
un autre intégrer ses acteurs
associatifs dans le cadre d'un bénévolat
sans pour autant demander à des
bénévoles d'aller au-delà de leur rôle
c'est-à-dire il est pas question de leur
confier un groupe de 20 enfants pour
faire pour partager le plaisir de lire
par exemple si c'est pas possible ça
donc je pense mais ce sont des forces
vives locales qui peuvent aussi être
intégrées à condition de bien les
organiser les structurer et et les
conduire avec une certaine capacité au
sourire plutôt que à y voir des
difficultés euh bon je je vais m'arrêter
là mais pour nous voy
je conclurai sur deux points quand même
rapidement on voit bien que quand on
regarde cette question
euh ça repose enfin les rythmes
scolaires reposent la question des
rythmes des familles et des rythmes de
notre société aussi hein d'une manière
générale et que je l'ai dit à un instant
tout à l'heure ça repose la question de
de la conciliation de la vie familiale
et de la vie professionnelle bon je
pense qu'on a la chance dans un pays que
comme le NRE quand même et c'est
sûrement pas tout à fait indépendant de
la de la qualité de la politique
familiale qui est conduit quand même qui
est conduite dans notre pays depuis
depuis de nombreuses années euh bon un
taux d'activité des femmes important ça
n'empêche qu'on a un taux de natalité
conséquent qui permet quasiment le
renouvellement des générations mais que
ça suppose effectivement que les
familles les jeunes familles qui
accueillent ces enfants et bien est des
outils pour gérer cette conciliation
entre vie familiale et vie
professionnelle et que ce changement des
rythmes scolaires et bien ça nous invite
probablement à à peut-être alors
peut-être est-ce fait nous l'avons
peut-être pas lu suffisamment enfin
Patricia pourra aussi le dire mais il me
semble que le monde économique
l'entreprise doit peut-être être
impliquée dans cette dans cette
réflexion alors je dis pas que c'est
bien évidemment le le l'élément magique
qui va nous donner des solutions
immédiates c'est pas ça que je veux dire
mais c'est que c'est bien évidemment un
acteur tout à fait fondamental dans dans
dans la vie d'une société qui doit aussi
être concerné par cette question hein et
bon nous en tout cas l'UNAF c'est une
expression qu'on qu'on formule
régulièrement hein et puis je le disais
oui c'est une occasion aussi d'ouvrir
d'ouvrir les les l'école sur sur son
territoire et et à l'ensemble des
acteurs qui vivent autour d'elle et
enfin je dis pour conclure je dirais que
c'est forcément un travail qui doit
s'inscrire dans la durée je pense qu'il
faut aussi que enseignants élus acteurs
associatifs divers sur un territoire et
famille ben je pense que bon je je l'ai
dit plusieurs fois vous je pense que
vous verrez que pour nous c'est
important c'est un travail qui s'inscrit
dans la durée et autour duquel ben il
faut chercher
progressivement des des réponses au aux
questions qui restent posées Dieu sait
s'il y en a s'il y en a un grand nombre
encore qu'il faut résoudre et que ça
doit
mobiliser l'ensemble de de la communauté
éducative hein et et la communauté
éducative et bien c'est bien sûr pour
nous tous les acteurs que j'ai évoqué à
plusieurs reprises que ce soit les élus
les enseignants les parents les familles
les acteurs associatifs les acteurs
économiques parce que pourquoi
une mobilisation de la communauté
éducative euh parce que c'est bien elle
avec cette diversité d'acteurs qui si on
on revient au sens premier du travail
qui est conduit depuis déjà longtemps à
partir de la Conférence nationale sur
les rythmes jusqu'à aujourd'hui hein on
a vu que il y avait effectivement une
une une diversité d'approche de la
question et bien c'est parce qu'on remet
on remet par cette réflexion l'enfant au
au cœur de la démarche et au cœur de de
l'avenir de notre société et je crois
que
c'est
je en vous disant ça je je je je pense à
à l'événement mondial qu'on vit
aujourd'hui avec la la disparition de
Nelson Mandela et je crois mais je je ne
voudrais pas écorcher un propos qu'il
tenait il disait souvent que ce qui se
fait pour moi sans moi se fait contre
moi ben je crois que c'est vrai que si
on veut que ce soit l'enfant il faut
peut-être qu'on concerne effectivement
l'enfant dans notre démarche je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté et
excusez-moi d'avoir été trop
long monsieur Guillaume merci infiniment
de cette présentation très exhaustive
très intéressante et surtout très
pragmatique dans la dans le déroulé de
vos différentes propositions ça va
beaucoup enrichir effectivement notre
notre travail de fond que nous faisons
sur cette réform merci à vous je vais
immédiatement donner la parole à Madame
la rapporteur madame Cartron
oui monsieur monsieur le Président j'ai
beaucoup vos propos sont nous ont dressé
un tableau qui je trouve est très
réaliste très approfondi et je dois dire
que j'ai beaucoup apprécié alors j'ai
deux ou trois questions pour aller plus
loin vous avez pointé un certain nombre
de de de d'incompréhension et vous avez
dit sans doute les famillees n'ont pas
compris le pourquoi de cette réforme et
je le partage
euh d'ailleurs j' j'en avais saisi le
ministre en disant peut-être qu'il
aurait fallu que le ministre s'adresse
aux familles peut-être que c'était pas
non plus la bonne solution pour vous
est-ce que vous avez une idée de qui
peut être à la fois légitime pour être
entendu par les familles et quel type de
de de de support ou de message on peut
faire parce que je crois qu'il y a
nécessité à revenir sur ce que vous avez
bien exprimé le bien fondé de
cette mise en place des rythmes comment
peut-on voilà toucher les familles avec
pour et qu'ell reçoivent le message
comme un message qui n'est pas un
message entre guillemets de propagande
mais qui est un message de pédagogie et
d'explication ça c'était la première
question je les pose les trois à la
suite
euh vous avez très justement pointé euh
que là dans la réforme des rimes nous
touchons et c'est bien c'est c'est une
des des questions que n'ont pas compris
les parents souvent j'entends ils disent
mais finalement on nallège pas le temps
puisque la journée est la même mais vous
allevez donc bien comment faire
comprendre que il y a le temps
d'apprentissage scolaire qui lui est
modifié mais après comme vous l'avez dit
le temps social et le temps des familles
il reste contraint par des
préoccupations et vous avez pointé
l'absence ou la nécessité de solliciter
le monde économique et là j'aurais une
question à vous poser est-ce que vous
avez eu des des remonté de la part des
familles pour lesquels des des femmes
ont
modifié leur temps de
travail c'est-à-dire parce que bon
ponctuellement j'ai entendu des exemples
on voit certaines personnes qui ne qui
avaient un temps partiel et ne
travaillait pas le mercredi matin on
repris à travailler est-ce que cela on
l'a ou est-ce qu'on pourrait aussi avoir
cette indication de savoir si des
familles ont modifié justement
l'organisation de leur temps de travail
suite à la mise en place de ces rythmes
et puis vous avez très justement pointé
cette
surconsommation
d'activité qui n'est pas forcément
bénéfique pour les enfants mais comment
gérer la contradiction entre ce que vous
avez pointé et ce que je crois tous les
pédopyat
c'est-à-dire ce besoin de ne rien faire
ce besoin de
rêver mais qui est très angoissant pour
les familles ou
anxiogènes si on leur dit ben non ils
vont être là dans un espace à pouvoir
s'allonger sur des coussin voilà ils
vont dire mais c'est pas ça qu'est-ce
qu'on leur propose là
encore comment arriver on a on a
besoin donc de ne pas trop porter sans
arrêt cette revendication de l'activité
la plus la plus élaborée puisqu'on
compare quand on dit des inégalités
entre le rural et l'urbain on a
l'impression que dans l'urbain on ne
ferait que des choses hautement
intellectuelles et que dans le rural ce
serait peut-être moins moins performant
alors que ben non mais voilà
rêver peut-être se promener dans la
nature justement ça ça peut être aussi
important voilà et je voulais revenir
sur un un petit point que vous avez dit
et qui et qui
pardon mais c'est peut-être que j'ai mal
entendu ou mal exprimé en fait on n'a
pas allégé le temps d'apprentissage on a
modifié c'est il y a toujours autant
d'heur de
cours
voilà avait il y avait 25 avant donc ah
mais c'était pas de l'enseignement
c'était une heure de concertation mais
je suis d'accord avec vous qu'il y a de
notre temps il y avait 27h exactement
c'est ça on est passé de 2 on a même eu
30 ouiou voilà donc c'est vrai que on a
on n pas modifié le nombre d'heures
d'apprentissage on essaie de mieux les
répartir et comme vous avez dit plutôt
le matin puisque c'était des situations
meilleures voilà écoutez je vais je vais
pas être plus longue bien je vous donne
la parole pour des réponses à Madame la
rapporteur merci Madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente si vous
m'autorisez je vais quand même de
éventuellement demander à Patricia Ouman
si elle peut ajouter des éléments parce
que elle vit au quotidien en tant que
coordinatrice du pôle éducation à lunaf
des choses et en terme de de d'aspect
quantitatif je pense qu'elle peut avoir
des choses intéressante à ajouter moi je
je vais très très rapide sur les trois
questions la première moi si vous voulez
vous avez tout à l'heure utiliser le
qualificatif de pragmatique je vais
rester très pragmatique par rapport à ça
le message aux familles euh bon
reconnaissons qu'il y a quand même eu un
peu de rapidité bon je vais pas dire de
précipitation mais bon le le le mot
mesfleur quand même un peu hein entre
entre janvier 2013 et la rentrée 2013 il
s'est quand même écoulé peu de temps
pour modifier autant de choses en même
temps et concernant autant d'acteurs et
et autour autour de de de l'enfant qui
est quand même le trésor pour les
familles et pour l'humanité donc euh
sans doute qu'il y a eu bon cette
rapidité
cette bon qui qui a sans doute
désarçonné un petit peu les les les les
acteurs mais par contre par rapport au
message moi je crois beaucoup à à la
proximité pour le faire et c'est je
pense dans
l'explication progressive au fur et à
mesure qu'on trouve des réponses aux
questions et aux problématiques qu'il
faut résoudre que l'on peut faire
avancer ce message et faire en sorte que
les parents certes mais pas que les
parents l'ensemble des acteurs
s'approprie effectivement les les les
fondamentaux de l'objectif des objectifs
de la réforme moi je crois beaucoup à
cette proximité alors y a-t-il aussi en
parallèle un message bon plus plus
national plus global très honnêtement je
n'ai pas la réponse à cela mais en tout
cas où je je suis convaincu et c'est
peut-être mon quotidien de de petit m
rural qui me faut au contact tous les
matins je c'était encore le cas ce matin
très tôt avant que je ne prenne le train
pour venir vous voir euh c'est vrai que
on sait bien que c'est dans cette
proximité que ce qu'on qu'on fait passer
des messages euh bon qui qui nuancent
qui font avancer qui font donc moi je
pense que alors oui si effectivement euh
chacun des acteurs reste dans son coin
euh on n'y arrivera pas moi je pense que
c'est vraiment notre capacité à à réunir
les gens autour de cela qui feront
passer progressivement des messages sur
la deuxème question par rapport aux
familles qui pourrai effectivement
modifier leur temps de travail alors là
euh on n'a pas si vous voulez de mesures
suffisamment exhaustive de la question
c'est une question qui a été posée puis
qu'on a fait une petite enquête hein
c'est c'est un peu trop tôt voilà c'est
un peu tôt c'est vrai qu'il y a
peut-être des femmes qui peuvent
renégocier aussi leur temps partiel en
essayant de partir plus tôt pour aller
chercher leurs enfants à l'école et et à
la place du mercredi matin B ça ça
paraît une une idée enfin je vois ma
collègue qui a deux petits enfants c'est
des choses qu'elle pourrait qu'elle
pourrait envisager mais c'est encore
trop tôt pour que mais il faut aussi
c'est vrai qu'on a n'a pas entendu le
monde de l'entreprise on sait pas aussi
les les réactions des employeurs par
rapport à ça et et je pense qu'il faut
qu' qu'ils les motivé pour suivre le
mouvement
euh pour se réadapter enfin tout le
monde sait que les quand on s'adresse
aux femmes de d'enfants petits c'est on
prend pas des réunions le mercredi
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
enfin les chiffres de l'adresse le monde
beaucoup d'enfants sont gardés par leur
leur mère le mercredi donc ou leur père
voilà mais plutôt par leur
mère donc il va falloir aussi peut-être
rechanger tout ça voilà mais par contre
madame la rapporteur votre question est
importante pour nous parce que je l'ai
peut-être indiqué trop rapidement tout à
l'heure notre notre souhait notre
volonté à l'UNAF c'est effectivement
toujours en complémentarité avec les
associations de parents d'élèves qui qui
ont bien sûr leur regard de de de
d'usager et je mets beaucoup de
guillemet de l'école sur justement
comment les choses vont évoluer il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on utilise vraiment le
réseau associatif qui est le nôtre hein
bon 7500 associations sur le terrain qui
sont pas toutes impliquées de la même
façon autour des questions d'éducation
et de jeunesse mais c'est quand même des
lieux d'observation tout à fait
intéressants sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc il faut qu'on continue à
regarder ça de de de de près et voir
comment les choses vont évoluer sur la
troisème question ben je pense que il y
a il y a il y a peut-être un point
important sur cette question de la
surconsommation et de la suractivité
c'est le choix aussi des activités hein
je je bon très vite on a parlé de euh
d'activités sportives et ce bon mais du
sport il y en a déjà dans dans les
programmes de l'école donc il faut pas
non plus qu'on surrajoute des Don faut
je pense qu'il faut plutôt aussi là euh
vraiment réfléchir à ce qui peut être
complémentaire hein de ce que les
enfants ont déjà dans leur dans leur
programme et puis qui peut effectivement
euh être très concrètement dans le sens
de l'objectif visé c'est-à-dire euh une
pression à moindri et et que les temps
que nous consacrons avec les enfants
dans une classe parce que c'est quand
même dans la classe avec l'instituteur
enfin excusez-moi avec le professeur des
écoles maintenant he qui que que les
choses se jouent quand même he et donc
c'est là qu'il faut que les enfants ai
cette cette capacité à à assimiler bon
donc le choix des activités par rapport
vous avez évoqué le monde urbain et le
monde rural moi je pense que c'est
d'abord bon la limite des fois elle est
difficile à trouver hein moi je je peux
considérer que je suis dans le monde
rural parce que j'ai encore qure
exploitations agricoles importantes sur
sur la commune dans le au sein de
laquelle je vis mais je suis à 6 km de
la capitale régionale donc voyez on
pourrait dire qu'on est en urbain ou
mais pourtant j'ai l'impression d'être
au milieu des champ moi il me semble que
par rapport à ça il faut utiliser les
potentialités aussi locales je pense que
le le monde rural offre des choses
extraordinaire pour les enfants en terme
d'observation de confrontation à la vie
et cetera peut-être plus riche même que
parfois des kilos de béton pour ne pas
dire des tonnes et donc donc là encore
je crois que qu'est-ce qui est important
c'est quand même de créer des enfin de
permettre à nos enfants et à nos
petits-enfants de de de de progresser
vers une capacité à être libre à être
ouvert à être sain corps et d'esprit je
dirais et et et pouvoir estê en capacité
de discernement et et de ne pas tomber
dans le piège des sirènes et par bon
parfois qu'on nous chante donc moi je
pense que c'est ça qui est important et
et Dieu sait si cette question euh et
c'était un point qui pour nous avait été
important sur le la la concertation et
et la réflexion sur la Conférence
nationale avant sur les rythmes
scolaires c'est la question des
décrocheurs bon je pense que c'est quand
même des problèmes tout à fait
fondamentaux ça et là je pense que il
faut aussi qu'on intègre tout ça dans
notre réflexion hein et et peut-être que
les décrocheurs moi je j'aime pas trop
trop le terme est-ce que c'est pas
plutôt une institution décrochante
plutôt que des enfants décrocheurs hein
est-ce que c'est parce que tout
simplement à un moment donné ce qu'on
leur a proposé ne correspondait pas à
leur capacité et à leur intérêt à leur
motivation bon je je suis pas je je vais
pas développer des expériences mais bon
moi j'ai été effectivement toute ma vie
au contact de jeunes dans le cadre de de
l'enseignement mais sous le sous s un un
petit ministère technique hein c'était
le ministère de l'Agriculture donc une
bien petite maison mais qui avait qui
avait qui avait une particularité c'est
que la diversité de ces composantes
faisait que sur le plan pédagogique et
sur la prise en compte du jeune dans sa
globalité et en s'appuyant sur ses
atouts plutôt que sur ses limites hein
parce que on a quand même un souci nous
on s'attarde beaucoup plus à mesurer ce
que les gens ne savent pas plutôt que de
regarder ce que les gens savent et que
là je crois que c'est aussi important ça
voyez et et pour moi cette question de
la mobilisation sur les territoires ça
ça fait partie de ça excusez-moi madame
la président
je suisop c'est de l'enthousiasme merci
beaucoup c'est c'est même communicatif
nous avons une question de Monsieur
Martin madame duchen également tout à
l'heure oui madame Gillot également très
bien et je je terminerai également par
une question donc monsieur Mar oui merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président j'ai beaucoup apprécié tout ce
que vous avez dit c'est un large tour
d'horizon des problèmes que nous
connaissons tous et j'ai retenu certains
de vos propos en par ulier quand vous
dites il y a eu précipitation et il y a
eu un peu trop de rapidité je crois que
ça c'est ind déniame puis une formule du
président Mandela qui dit ce qui se fait
pour moi sans moi ça pose un vrai
problème parce que ce que vous nous
évoquez c'est le résultat de réflexion
qui sort un peu du problème des
remontées de terrain or n'ut-il pas étit
préférable que la situation de dialogue
s'organise avant que l'opération ne soit
lancée car toutes les réflexions
n'auraient pas été imaginées mais au
moins on en aurait retenu quelques-unes
et puis vous parlez de l'propriation de
la réforme et bien lorsqu'on construit
quelque chose on s'en sent plus
propriétaire qu'après coup quand on vous
invite à particip Pasin c'est un peu
cela alors ne serait-il pas plus
judicieux aujourd'hui compte tenu de
cette opération qui est lancée
maintenant d'en faire une
expérimentation et qu'on tienne compte
de tous ces éléments qui ne peuvent que
positiver le problème parce que sur le
fond on peut imaginer qu'il y a de très
bonnes réflexions qu'il y a de très
bonnes opérations à réaliser et que cela
va dans l'intérêt de l'enfant mais
est-ce que
l'exérimentations dans les années qui
viennent ne serait ne seraiit pas
préféraable à ce qui se produit pour que
tout le monde se sente participer à
l'opération et que les uns et les autres
s'approprient quand le terrain aura été
consulté cette
opération merci Monsieur Martin madame
Gilou
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur je suis ici j'ai excusez-moi je
n'ai pas entendu toute votre
intervention mais la fin m'a aussi
convaincu que bon je partage beaucoup de
ce que vous avez dit ayant moi-même mis
en place la la refondation la réforme de
de l'école dès la rentrée 2013 j'ai
mesuré la difficulté qu'il y avait dans
la compréhension dans l'appropriation et
surtout dans la mobilisation de
l'ensemble des partenaires à coproduire
un projet coma au bénéfice de l'enfant
dans l'intért supérieur de l'enfant donc
je vais revenir sur deux deux points que
vous avez évoqué qui que j'aimerais bien
que vous alliez plus loin sur lesquel
j'aimerais bien que vous alliez plus
loin notamment quand vous dites que le
changement des rythmes scolaires devrait
impliquer le monde économique alors on a
eu un petit échange là tout de suite sur
ce que ça pouvait aller ça pouvait être
bon vous visiblement vous envisagez
madame qui s'agirait de d'assouplir les
les les les les horaires de travail des
des mamans pour pour récupérer leurs
enfants ça ça peut être ça effectivement
alors je termine mais si vous si c'est
ça ça veut dire que du coup les enfants
ne profitent pas des activités
complémentaires qui sont proposées dans
l'école et qui effectivement en en en en
prenant en charge les enfants sur un
temps plus long à l'école c'estd 27h
avec 24 he d'enseignement et 3h
d'activités souple ouvert qui ne propose
pas de la suractivité mais qui
permettent aux enfants en collectif
ensemble de découvrir des des
connaissances des sensibilité qui ne
découvririt pas par ailleurs bon
j'aimerais savoir comment vous envisagez
les choses et puis est-ce que vous ça
pourrait être aussi que les entreprises
s'impliquent dans un cofinancement dans
un apport financier à la couverture de
certaines activités qui sont mises en
place par les par les communes ensuite
vous dites que c'est quelque chose qui
doit s'inscrire dans la durée moi je
suis tout à fait de votre avis même si
bon les fait de sidération il y a
toujours des personnes qui considèrent
que les choses ont été trop vite que il
faudrait une expérimentation enfin bon
les résultats les analyses qui sont
faites sur la capacité de nos enfants à
réussir aujourd'hui dans le domaine
scolaire montre bien qu'il y avait
urgence quand même à à à prendre des
disposition et que attendre aurait pu
aussi provoquer les mêmes les mêmes
difficultés car on voit bien que les les
les les les projets de territoire sont
sont divers en fonction des des
potentialités locales que vous avez
évoqué hein des richesses locales et on
peut pas arriver à un
dispositif équivalent sur l'ensemble du
territoire la seule chose équivalente
c'est les 24 heures d'enseignement
aménagé différemment avec cinq matinées
de meilleur temps scolairire et puis 3h
que vous espérez gratuite pour les
familles que moi je pense aussi qu'
doivent être gratuit mais avec une
organisation qui permet aux enfants de
profiter d'un meilleur temps de l'enfant
il y a du le temps de l'enfant le temps
de l'élève et puis ceci s'inscrit
effectivement dans un temps social qui
est peut-être un peu plus difficile à
apprécier cont tenu des habitudes des
familles et des angoisses des familles
au regard des résultats qu'ils attendent
de l'école voilà j'ai encore une
dernière question si vous me le
permettez euh elle elle est plus plutôt
lié à une crainte qui m'anime suite à
des propos que j'ai pu entendre de la
part de certains parents qui me disaient
ceci nous c'est un c'est à peine
caricatural nous nous choisirons l'école
nous demanderons éventuellement une
dérogation en fonction des activités qui
seront proposées à mon enfant après les
heures de cours ça fait très très peur
dans dans la mesure où nous sommes quand
même les représentants des collectivités
locales et les maères sont très attachés
au au maintien de leur école dans leur
commune donc si effectivement il devait
y avoir un mouvement en ce sens-là cela
pourrait euh signifier la fermeture de
certaines écoles par manque d'effectif
vous parlez de la gratuité bien sûr
c'est c'est important pour les familles
mais néanmoins sans doute dans certaines
communes des des plus petites qui n'ont
peut-être pas de monde associatif
disponible en journée parce que c'est
quand même à 15h qu'on va leur demander
d'intervenir elles seront peut-être
amenés à assurer un service payant et là
encore une fois de plus est-ce que les
parents vont peut-être à ce moment-là
plutôt opter pour des communes où
l'activité est gratuite parce que tous
les services sont en place depuis très
très longtemps il y a y a il y a une
dérive qui me qui me fait craindre le
pire pour les petites communes donc
j'aimerais j'aimerais vraiment avoir
votre avis là-dessus donc je vous
redonne la parole pour les différentes
les différentes questions qui vous ont
été posées merci
merci madame la Présidente c'est c'est
vrai que les questions sont difficiles
sont difficiles bon Monsieur Martin
monsieur le sénateur c'est c'est vrai
que vous évoquez la question de
l'appropriation donc fallait-il une
expérimentation ou une
généralisation euh bon ça n'est pas
esquiver la question mais bon il
n'appartient pas je dirais à l'UNAF de
de se de se prononcer là-dessus hein euh
bon euh je l'ai évoqué je l'ai dit je
l'ai dit bon je pense que bon ça a été
exprimé au sein du conseil
d'administration de l'UNAF hein qui
regroupe quarantaines de personnes de l'
qui couvre l'ensemble du territoire et
l'ensemble des mouvements qui composent
l'UNAF donc une grande diversité avec
une diversité je dirais euh par leur par
leur entrée sur les questions de la
famille mais aussi par leur repère
philosophique voire religieux pour
certains mais aussi de projet de société
donc c'est avec ce pluralisme mais cette
grande diversité que que le le Conseil
exprime des des positionnements et c'est
vrai que la question de la rapidité a
été évoquée donc je je la je la redis
parce que ça par contre c'est vrai que
bon après sur la question faut
expérimentation
généralisation moi je dirais portons
beaucoup d'attention à ce qui va se
passer dans les mois qui viennent hein
donc parce que effectivement ça va pas
être aisé de passer de 4000 à 4000 hein
donc si je peux prendre ces deux
chiffres qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
hein en tout cas sur la question de
l'appropriation
euh excusez-moi de me répéter mais moi
moi je je je crois beaucoup quand même
et c'est peut-être quelque chose qu'on a
un peu oublié dans un pays comme le
nôtre c'est je crois beaucoup à
l'initiative locale et aux capacités des
gens à créer leur propre fonctionnement
sur des bien évidemment que quand on
parle de l'éducation ils font des il
faut des repères structurants il faut
bon qui ne peuvent être que je dirais en
correspondance avec le territoire
national mais après je pense qu'il y a
toujours des espaces où cette capacité
d'initiative locale il faut
effectivement lui donner de la liberté
alors bon je ne réponds pas à votre
question j'en suis tout à fait conscient
mais vous me permettrez de ne pas aller
plus loin hein dans sinon je sortirais
de mon rôle de l'UNAF et je me ferai
taper sur les doigts par mon Président
ce soir
non je permettez-moi cette petite
boutade donc je je n'ai pas bien noté
votre madame Gilot excusez-moi madame
oui madame laassatrice bon sur la
question des entreprises et des rythmes
avec les rythmes bon ce qu'on a voulu
dire nous c'est que et et Madame Ouman
la
préciser sur cette question là non plus
il y a pas de réponse toute faite mais
je pense que aujourd'hui quand on
regarde on a évoqué 84 % des des des des
mamans ont une activité professionnelle
aujourd'hui donc on voit bien que bon le
travail féminin fait partie du du cadre
économique de notre pays et en même
temps on voit bien qu'il y a un certain
nombre de maman voire parfois de papas
qui se sont aussi organisés en fonction
des rythmes de l'école bon il y avait
beaucoup de mamans qui par exemple ne
travaillaient pas le mercredi je pense
que une autre organisation d'IT va sans
doute amener les gens à à à poser un
certain nombre de questions à
l'entreprise en général donc je pense
qu'il faut quand je dis que quand on dit
nous que l'entreprise doit être
concernée c'est que elle va être
concerné par ce questionnement et
comment comment va-t-elle y répondre je
pense que c'est un c'est un point
important oui vous parliez de de la en
fait nous on parlait de la possibilité
pour les parents de venir chercher leurs
enfants à 15h30 par exemple ou 15h45 et
de pas le si il souhait enfin je sais
pas par exemple à Paris il y a des
activités le mar Lardi et le vendredi il
peut y avoir une certaine souplesse et
un choix enfin pour les parents de
laisser leur enfant à une activité par
exemple le vendredi et de venir chercher
le mardi enfin bon moi je pense que ce
qui est intéressant c'est d'avoir de la
souplesse de pas dire c'est une
obligation que tous les enfants aillent
à toutes ses activités et une obligation
que tous les parents aillent chercher
les enfants à telleure enfin comme de de
la même façon que les les il y avait des
enfants qui étaient chez leur gardés par
leur famille le mercredi matin et
d'autres qui allaient à des activité le
mercredi matin dans un centre
d'animation à côté enfin bon laisser une
souplesse et une décision souplesse de
décision au famille voilà c'est c'est
pas effectivement c'est ça peut être
dommage que les enfants ne puissent pas
en profiter mais mais il y a pas de
raison c'est c'est un choix familial
dans ce cas-là des des parents et de
l'enfant d'en profiter quoi mais ce qui
est bien c'est si
l'entreprise introduit aussi de la
souplesse au niveau des horaires il me
semble que que c'est quand même quelque
chose qui peut être enfin bon moi aussi
pour l'avoir vécu en ayant travaillé
dans le monde de l'entreprise très
contraint pendant des années je pense
que favoriser la souplesse notamment
dans les PME c'est c'est quelque chose
un combat qu'il faut mener qu'il faut
mener en changeant les rythmes scolaires
voilà sur votre question madame la
Présidente sur effectivement la crainte
hein que vous exprimez par rapport aux
écoles et et à des familles qui
pourraient effectivement choisir leur
école en fonction des activités qui
seraient proposées
euh
euh ce ce risque là existe sans doute
bon ça n'est pas forcément une remontée
qu'on a eu en grand nombre mais mais
elle elle est présente hein ce alors
après je crois que
euh on sait bien que la compéten scola
aujourd'hui qu' si on évoque la question
des toutes petites communes bon euh sur
36000 et un peu plus de communes on a
24000 en gros qui ont une école demain
avec effectivement la prise de
compétences par les communautés de
communes parfois parfois hein c'est pas
encore une une généralisation bien
évidemment
bon moi je crois que effectivement c'est
c'est une commune isolée qui serait
effectivement dans cette situationl moi
il me semble que des des pistes de
réponse par rapport à ça mais là aussi
c'est il faut être très pragmatique hein
je crois que c'est c'est de voir comment
avec son environnement proche on peut
travailler collectivement quoi pour
arriver à faire des propositions mais
mais euh probablement qu'on n'effacera
pas totalement le risque que vous avez
évoqué mais moi il me semble que il y a
peut-être des réponses là aussi à
construire en tenant compte des des
aussi des contraintes hein parce que bon
sur certains territoires ruraux les
distances peuvent être aussi un frein
les bon voilà il y a la question des
transports il y a tout ça bon mais je
pense que là vous voyez il me semble que
quand on évoquait la souplesse tout à
l'heure y compris de la hiérarchie de
l'éducation nationale moi je crois qu'il
faut que l'éducation nationale tion par
rapport à ça soit très consciente que il
va falloir accompagner et et et pas
accompagner uniquement en disant les
choses se passent de telle heure à telle
heure et cetera enfin excusez-moi je
vais pas caricaturer parce que c'est
plus sérieux que ça mais mais mais
plutôt essayer de voir comment avec les
acteurs d'un territoire si modeste
soit-il et c'est pas péjoratif puisse
construire effectivement ensemble donc
voilà mais mais votre crainte je
l'entends bien mais
voilà mer beaucoup merci de tous ces
éclairages de tous ces précieuses
propositions dont nous tiendrons
évidemment compte monsieur faukon est-ce
que vous
souhatiez ah je vous en prie par rapport
au à la liberté moi j'entends ENF
j'entends qu'il faut s'il y a pas une
obligation par nature les parents ont la
liberté de de mettre leur enfant ou pas
mais il me semble que des laissant o un
engagement de participer à une activité
surtout quand elle est fait dans le
cadre d'un cycle moi je vois chez moi il
y a quand même un engagement l'école
c'est pas le bout de gondol du
supermarché c'estàdire si on s'engage à
suivre un cycle pendant 4 C séquence
c'est éducatif pour l'enfant de lui dire
même si ça lui plaît pas il faut qu'il
Ti Al je suis arrivé en retard alors
peut-être j'ai pas bien compris ce que
vous vouliez dire c'est vrai on est
conscient de ce problème notamment pour
lire et faire lire puisque c'est une
activité où il y a des bénévoles qui
lisent à des f si les enfants partent en
plein milieu ça va ça va pas il faut que
effectivement quand on s'engage encore
une toute dernière question de Madame la
rapporteur et je m'y associe totalement
voilà je on se l' soufflé à l'oreille
donc je voulais demander est-ce que vous
avez eu vous une enquête ou je ne sais
pas des remontées euh des parents entre
le choix du mercredi ou du samedi matin
est-ce que vous avez mené cela et parce
que quelquefois on nous pose la question
vous le savez bien les parentsisent oui
mais le mercredi c'était des rendez-vous
c'était l'organisation de est-ce que
vous avez eu ça et et est-ce que voilà
est-ce que vous avez un sentiment à nous
donner je vais vous faire une réponse de
Normand mais que je ne suis pas mais de
oui j'habite la Normandie mais je ne
suis pas originaire de Normandie donc je
voudrais pas m'approprier la qualité des
qui mais donc on a eu effectivement hein
les les les deux mais quand même le
mercredi était très majoritaire mais on
a eu des associations qui nous ont fait
remonter que le samedi pouvait être une
hypothèse mais voyez au plan national il
y a d'autres enquêtes qui ont été faites
nous on a on a effectivement sollicité
l'ensemble du réseau des UDAF il y a 100
UDAF donc on na pas les remontées
précises de toutes encore aujourd'hui
mais on continue à à mener notre
travail bon le samedi ressort de façon
très minoritaire quand même bon très
très minoritaire bon euh je vais pas
développer les raisons mais bon il y en
a qu'on connaît que vous connaissez
mieux que nous oui il il se trouve
qu'avec madame la rapporteur nous nous
partageons tout à fait l'avis et on va
pas le contester des des experts qui
disent qu'il serait plus plus équilibré
pour l'enfant euh de le scolariser le
samedi matin mais nous appartient pas
aujourd'hui de porter un jugement de par
rapport au choix des parents madame
duchè oui en revanche je pense que euh
l'UNAF a peut-être aussi un travail de
auprès des parents en leur disant
écoutez le samedi matin ce serait mieux
vraiment manifestement ce serait mieux
alors je sais que l'exemple de
Paris qui qui a quand même 2 jours a
fait que 6 he de
cours pour de cours de vrais cours alors
que le prince principal motif par le
ministre de de d'imposer les rythmes
scolaires c'était justement pour qu'il
n'y ait pas ces 6 heur par jour de cours
alors du coup si si les associations
familiales ne parlent pas du samedi mais
qui va en parler qui voilà donc là du
coup je je je voyez je je rebondit
là-dessus parce que c'est je pense très
important monsieur le Président encore
une dernière réponse puisque nous devons
continuer nos auditions j'entends votre
votre réflexion madame et effectivement
on a donné l'occasion aussi parce que
bon l'UNAF organise de temps en temps un
certain nombre de de colloques de
réunions de travail de groupes de
travail et avec un certain nombre
d'experts sur cette question et
notamment les chronobiologistes on a
aussi conduit un certain nombre de
travaux mais bon on voit bien que
derrière cette question il y a aussi
toute la question aussi j'ai j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure le pluralisme la
diversité et cetera il y a aujourd'hui
aussi un certain nombre d'organisations
familiales qui font que le samedi je
parle pas des des problèmes économique
des organisations bon on voit bien alors
après bon on l'a dit la la régularité
des rythmes sur les sur les 5 jours donc
lundi mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi bon
a aussi présente aussi quand même des
intérêts qu'il faut peut-être le choix
éant fait cultiver et et justement
essayer de faire fonctionner avec
l'adhésion des parents dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant et et je reviens parce que on
fait un travail important en ce moment
là-dessus sur les enfants et les écrans
hein euh bon moi je fais partie des gens
qui considèrent que on entre dans dans
une ère nouvelle extraordinaire mais qui
présente tellement aussi de danger et
que c'est par rapport à ça qu'il faut
réfléchir mais il faut pas bien
évidemment refuser cette cette nouvelle
ère dans laquelle on entre c'est un
monde nouveau bon il faut y entrer
positivement y compris et outiller les
enfants pour qu'ils en qu'ils puissent
en puiser tout ce que tout ce que sera
leur monde mais effectivement faut faut
y travailler très bien monsieur le
Président Madame human merci beaucoup de
votre
contribution Monsieur le Directeur
Général mesdames et
messieurs président du conseil
d'administration monsieur le Président
du conseil d'administration euh nous
sommes très heureux de pouvoir vous vous
entendre aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
auditions que nous organisons euh pour
la mission commune d'information sur les
rythmes scolaires nous
souhaitons aboutir à des propositions
concrètes à la fois euh pour l'ensemble
des des attentes qui qui nous sont
remontées les familles les les
enseignants euh les élus également donc
nous nous étions impatients de vous
entendre dans la mesure où vous faites
partie de d'un des d'une des
problématique majeur qui nous remonte
régulièrement c'est le financement de
cette réforme des rythmes scolaires et
donc monsieur le Président je vous
invite à nous faire une présentation de
votre engagement monsieur le Président
du conseil
d'administration merci mesdames mesdames
messieurs si vous voulez cette question
effectivement de la l'accompagn en fait
de cette réforme des des rythmes
éducatifs bon a été présenté à notre
conseil d'administration alors il faut
reconnaître que les conditions dans
lesquelles nous avons été saisies bon
n'ont pas forcément recueilli un accueil
très favorable c'est dire qu'on a été un
peu mis à l'écart très honnêtement de la
construction de cette réforme même et je
dirais que c'est parce qu'il y a eu un
certain nombre d'élus qui ont dit mais
d'habitude sur ce genre d'activité
périscolaire les CAF intervenaient que
d'un seul coup je dirais on s'est
retourner vers nous en disant ben voilà
vous forcément vous devez financer quoi
mais financer quoi dans quelles
conditions donc beaucoup d'incertitude
demeurit donc nous avions pris
l'initiative avec notre ministère de
tutelle donc Madame
Bertinotti de de provoquer vraiment une
rencontre entre le le cabinet du
ministère de de l'éducation nationale et
nous-même en présence de notre ministère
de tutelle donc c'est ce qui a été fait
en février 2013 où là clairement on a
dit voilà c'est quelque chose qui va
impacter la vie des familles hein dans
le sens où voilà le une autre
organisation du temps scolaire a
forcément des incidents sur
l'organisation de de la vie familiale et
si les enfants doivent être libérés plus
tôt une organisation différente
retravailler le mercredi ou le samedi
matin euh il y aura des incidences sur
l'organisation vie familiale et donc
notre présence en tant que case
d'allocation familiale doit être aussi
en premier lieu à côté des parents donc
nous nous voulions effectivement être au
moins associé dans la dans la réflexion
et ce qui avait été demandé en février
je dirais c'était peut-être le béabas de
d'un premier échange et qu'au niveau de
chaque département il puisse y avoir une
rencontre entre les services académiques
de l'éducation nationale donc le le le
directeur le le dazen et puis du côté de
la CAF président direct acteur et et les
services de façon je dirais à à entendre
quel pouvait être les demandes d'un côté
et de l'autre et essayer de s'organiser
bon donc ce qui était conclu de notre
réunion de février c'était qu'il y ait
bon sous la cignature des deux ministres
monsieur payon madame bertinoti un
courrier invitant les daenes à aller à
la rencontre des CAF je dirais et
réciproquement bon ce courrier n'est
n'est jamais parti ce qu'il fait que bah
sur le terrain le bon sens à
heureusement en règle générale prévalut
que certains d'azen ont pris eux-même
l'initiative de rencontrer la CAF dans
d'autres cas c'était aussi la CAF bon
qui avait aussi l'habitude je dirais de
de de de relation courtoise Franch voilà
pour gérer tous ces temps périscolaires
et et et faire face à toutes les
difficultés qui sontah les difficultés
de terrain dans dans une telle
organisation voilà mais on est arrivé
aussi alors qu'on nég notre convention
d'objectif et de gestion puisque le
renouvellement intervenait au au 1er
janvier 2013 à je dirais voir au fur et
à mesure des mois et des semaines enfin
des semaines et des mois qui passaient
cette l'inscription un peu obligatoire
de notre participation financière dans
des conditions que personne ne ne nous
donnait vraiment le l'or enfin la
possibilité de d'organiser au mieux donc
nous avons effectivement fait part un
peu notre mécontentement bon à à à ce
niveau-là premièrement en disant que Ben
nos interventions étaient vraiment dans
un côté d'accompagnement des famille
mais d'accompagnement aussi éducatif des
enfants et que s'il fallait proposer
quelque chose c'était un peu dans
l'esprit dans lequel les CAF intervenit
jusque-l dans le domaine périscolaire
donc les activités du mercredi le soir
et cetera mais qu'il n'était pas
possible pour nous de de nous demander
en gros d'intervenir pour payer de la
garderie quoi hein la garderie du matin
bon qui est forcément nécessaire he pour
les parents de de trouver une solution
d'accueil entre le le début de leur
activité professionnel et et l'ouverture
de de l'école enfin au moins de de de
l'UR de classe mais c'était pas notre
notre rôle de d'intervenir à ce
niveau-là donc on avait clairement je
dirais mis un peu des barrières en
disant c'était bon pas de notre
responsabilité de d'intervenir sur un
temps qui soit simplement de de la
garderie donc nous avons bon néanmoins
continué de travailler et donc sommes
arrivés au moment de la signature de
notre COG à un compromis hein sur
l'intervention qui pourrait être celle
bon de la Caisse nationale et donc
par-dà des CAF sur ce ces temps en fait
éducatif donc parallèlement si je puis
dire nous avions travaillé aussi avec le
ministère la Jeunesse et des Sports
enfin le grand le grand nom de ce
ministère donc avec Madame FOURNERON
pour je dirais coélaborer un guide
l'accompagnement des élus sur
l'organisation de ces temps de ces temps
libérés et le le compromis auquel nous
sommes arrivé donc dans cette convention
d'objectif et de gestion c'est donc de
d'intervenir dès l'année 2013 alors
voilà sur une somme qui donc a été
inscrite à notre fond d'action sociale
he de 10 millions d'euros hein sur les
les lignes
pérééducatives donc renouvelé à hauteur
de
70 millions je crois à peu près 62
millions en 2000 en 2014 pour arriver à
un rythme de croisière de 250 millions
les années pleines si on peut dire 2015
16 et 17 hein puisque à partir le on
sera vraiment du 1er janvier 2015 au 31
décembre 2015 sur l'ensemble des enfants
de l'ensemble des communes du territoire
national alors il nous a été demandé
aussi et ça c'était voilà B c'est de
faire un peu du compromis
d'intervenir à à hauteur de là aussi 60
un peu plus de 60 millions d'eurosin sur
le fond d'amorçage bon et c'était pas je
dirais que pour nous c'est un peu
compliqué parce que c'est la première
fois que dans notre Fond national
d'action sociale on va intervenir un peu
d' façon aveugle sur un fond public qui
est celui de des fonds d'amorsage donc
voilà ce à quoi nous étions donc arrivés
donc avec le le le ce compromis de la
convention d'objectif et de gestion
alors le je dirais que sur le terrain ce
que nous souhaitionsh c'était d'être
davantage associé à l'élaboration des
projets éducatifs de
territoire apportant l'expertise qui
pouvait être celle des caises de
location familiale dans l'accompagnement
éducatif de ces temps scolaireson euh il
y a eu ensuite donc une demande forte
hein de de de la part des élus de revoir
aussi les taux d'encadrement hein donc
l'accompagnement de de ces groupes
d'enfants donc il s'est abouti donc au
décret du 2 ha hein qui a PL donc sur
les 3 heures hein qui étaient cell des
quatre fois tr/4 d'heure libéré donc les
4 jours de de la semaine bon ça aboutit
donc à ce que le décret assouplisse pour
ces ce type d'activité là lié aux
3h donc un encadrement en fait bon je
dirais un plus de souplesse dans
l'encadrement puisque au lieu d'un pour
10 enfants on a un pour 14 et voilà bon
donc euh je dirais que voilà donc
l'ensemble des éléments portés à la à la
connaissance des des caises à loocation
familiale la demande des élus qui
essayaient je dirais bon voilà aussi
dans les difficultés qui est for qui
étaient forcément les l'heurs
d'organiser pour la rentrée scolaire bon
a abouti à ce compromis bon après on a
bien compris que la la demande
supplémentaire des des élus et
aujourd'hui qui sont confronté à la
difficulté en fait de
jutaposer une intervention en fait qui
est financé par la CAF sur une partie
des 3hures donc parfois 3/4 d'heure et
qui se prolonge par une activité qui
était une activité d'intervention de
longue date donc en gros d'avant la
réforme si je puis dire euh voilà
peut-être d'une heur qui se faisait tous
les soirs ou tous les quinzaines ou
voilà et donc le le la modification des
taux d'encadrement assoupli pour une
première partie et non assouplie pour la
seconde bon voilà nous nous incite à à
certainement à devoir y réfléchir et
nous attendons sur ce point un peu une
une saisine du Premier ministre qui a
évoqué lors du congrès des maires il y a
quelques il y a quelques semaines
désormais voilà un petit peu le le le
contexte dans lequel on s'est un peu vu
je dirais obligé mais euh faut quand
même insister sur le fait qu'on on ne
souhaitait pas non plus être à l'écart
de ce qui pouvait être une cause de
difficultés à rencontrer par les
familles mais voilà on a quand même fait
comprendre à plusieur reprises que on
avait pas beaucoup apprécié de pas avoir
été mis dans la boucle du départ bon qui
n'aurait pas sement assoupli tous les
problèmes y compris des des problèmes
financiers mais je pense que le dialogue
enfin c'est toujours ma conception un
peu de de de mon rôle c'est dans le
dialogue qu'on aurait peut-être pu aussi
bon éviter bon quelques difficultés ou
au moins bon permettre aux élus de
prendre la situation un peu plus en
amont et peut-être assouplir aussi bon
les difficultés ou applainir les
difficultés qui pouvait être lise l're
alors peut-être pour pour prolonger euh
ce que vient de dire président
Jean-Louis de Roussan d'abord une
première chose c'est que vous le savez
j'ai pris mes fonction après cet épisode
de négociation de la la COG donc je je
préférais évidemment que ce soit lui qui
qui rappelle ce ce élément de contexte
et puis deuxièmement vous le savez aussi
les caisses de sécurité sociale ont une
gouvernance un peu originale puisqu'il y
a un conseil d'administration il y a un
exécutif qui est le directeur mais c'est
il est clair que sur ce type de dossier
il faut qu'il a il faut qu'on marche sur
les deux pieds je vais peut-être avant
que on puisse passer aux questions
répondre aux questionnaire que vous nous
avez adressé sur les aspects financiers
puisque
c'était c'était les les sur ce point-là
que vous souhaitiez notamment interroger
la knaf et puis s'il y a des questions
plus précises de Frédéric marinat pour
les mêmes raisons je n'étais pas là donc
il connaiscoup mieux vous on pourra vous
donner les éléments alors sur les le
financement de la réforme des rythmes
scolaire on pourra vous donner un
tableau détaillé qui reprend les
chiffres présentés par le président il
faut savoir que sur la sur la période de
la COG lactnaf accompagne la réforme à
hauteur de 913 millions en 5 ans ce qui
est quand même une somme assez assez
significative alors que par ailleurs on
continue à verser la PSO périscolaire à
hauteur de 765 millions d'euros sur 5
ans et le CEJ est hauteur de 868
millions d'euros sur 5 ans je parle sous
contrôle de mou de gauche mais qui
visiblement est d'accord euh parce que
est-ce que vous pouvez traduire les
sigles alors la PSO c'est la
prestation comment prestation service
ordinaire c'est celle qui permet de
financer l'encadrement à hauteur de
05 50 centimes d'euros par par enfant et
puis le CEJ c'est ce qui permet de
financer le développement et notamment
les investissements à hauteur de 1 € par
heure c'est ça 0,5 € par heure ce
contrat enfant jeunesse enfance jeunesse
hein donc enfin tout ça pour dire que
l'engagement de la branche famille sur
cette réforme est important enfin il est
important alors d'abord parce que comme
le disait Jean-Louis deoussan c'est
notre vocation d'accompagner cette
activité périscolaire qui n'est pas une
activité d'enseignement mais qui est une
activité éducative et qui est qui relève
des missions de la branche famille et
dans la mesure où il y a une évolution
effectivement on peut chiffrer à hauteur
de 913 millions l'accompagnement de
l'évolution alors sur la deè question
c'était sur la question du du fond
d'amorçage la 2uxè et la 3è question
d'ailleurs le le fond d'amorçage il
était prévu et il est toujours prévu que
un financement uniquement en 2014 à
hauteur de 62 millions d'euros et il
n'est pas à ma connaissance prévue que
ce soit la branche famille qui vienne
alimenter la pérénisation
du fond d'amorçage et et si ça devait
être le cas d'abord ça pose je crois que
là c'est plus au président du conseil
d'administration de le dire qu'à moi
mais ça pose clairement un problème de
principe parce que autant notre
engagement sur l'accompagnement des
activités vériscolaires et a du sens
autant on peut se poser la question sur
sur le fond d'amorçage sauf à ce que sa
vocation change et et si c'était le
cas il faudrait à mon avis faire un
avenant à la convention d'objectif et de
gestion puisque les les sommes qui sont
telles que je viens de les vous savez
comment fonctionne les relations entre
l'État et les branches de la sécurité
sociale il y a une convention d'objectif
et de gestion c'est un dispositif que
j'ai moi-même géré dans plusieurs
branches donc qui qui qui donne de la
visibilité à l'action des régimes de
sécurité sociale et des branches du
régime général mais qui encadre aussi
dans la durée donc qui donne la
visibilité c'est pluré annuel mais qui
encadre dans la durée notre engage
engagement donc si on
devait supposer que ça voudrait dire
d'abord un que le fond d'amoral change
c'està-dire que on soit plus dans une
logique de financement péren des
activités prériscolaires ce qui est pour
l'instant pas le cas si ça et dans et
dans cette hypothèse ça voudrait dire
qu'il une un avenant la contif et de
gestion donc de toute façon et d'après
les informations que j'ai pour l'instant
il n'est pas question que la branche
famille Vienne alimenter la pérénisation
du fond fond d'amage je vous indique
juste R
l'effort vous posez la question de
savoir si l'effort au-delà de 2015 est
soutenable il est soutenable puisqu'il
est prévu s sauf cette question là il
est prévu dans la convention d'objectif
et de gestion un montant de 250 millions
d'euros par an c'est la première année
on est été à 100 millions bon on n pas
encore les estimations mais c'est
possible qu'on soit un peu au-delà quand
on aura la réalisation en 2014 je crois
que c'est 91 millions c'est ça et mais
bon c'est pareil c'est une phase de Moné
en charge mais à partir de 2015 on est à
250 millions d'euros chaque année donc
c'est soutenable à hauteur de 250
millions d'euros puisque c'est prévu
dans les financements de la branche
famille sur sur la durée alors vous
posez ensuite la question de
l'assouplissement du taux d'accadrement
des activités périscolaires alors et de
savoir pourquoi les cette possibilité ne
concerne que les 3 heures libérées par
la réforme des rythmes scolaires alors
d'abord euh la la la possibilité
effectivement a été ouverte par le
décret du 2 août alors elle est et c'est
sur ce sujet que il y a une discussion
en ce moment mais qui n'a pas encore été
comment dire qui n'a pas encore fait
l'objet d'une délibération du conseil
d'administration de de la knaf la
possibilité qui pourrait être ouverte et
qui est qui fait l'objet d'étude bon
vous savez sûrement qu'il y a des
discussions en cours sous lesgide du
cabinet du premier ministre entre les
représentants de de l'AMF et et
nous-mêmes et les différents ministères
et et le et et la
CNAF la possibilité qui serait utilisée
par le conditionnel puisque ces travaux
sont en cours la possibilité qui serait
utilisée et celle qui est prévue par le
le le décret du 2 août c'est la
possibilité de faire ces dérogations
dans le cadre de plan de pedt
alors pedt ça veut dire projet éducatif
projet éducatif de territoire hein donc
c'est mais ça suppose ce qui était pas
prévu par les textes jusqu'à présent ça
suppose que les CAF soient signataires
des projets éducatifs de territoire et
que cette possibilité soit ouverte dans
le cadre de de projets éducatifs de
territoire qui aurait vérifié ça alors
pourquoi pas par souci excessif du
formalisme juridique mais parce que
derrière la question du de l'encadrement
il y a la question des des de
fondamental et le conseil
d'administration
enfin le président tout à l'heure vient
de le dire est très sensible à ça de la
qualité et de la sécurité des activités
périscolaire euh il s'agit évidemment
pas en terme de qualité que ces
activités deviennent des activités de de
garderie euh je force le trait et puis
il y a aussi des questions de sécurité
alors c'est ces dérogations sont prévues
par le décret du 2 août dans le cadre
des pedt ce qui permet de garantir que
les activités qui feraient l'objet de
ces dérogation euh ben répondent à des
normes de de qualité et de sécurité
suffisante euh bon qui je crois qu'on a
tous intérêt à cela je sais que
parfois pu pour en avoir discuté avec le
président pélistar on a été un peu
soupçonné d'un peu de raidur
réglementaire sur ces sujetsl l'objectif
n'est pas d'appliquer les textes bien de
toute façon il s'applique mais c'est pas
d'appliquer les textes avec une une
rigidité cadavérique c'est l'objectif
c'est d'assurer la qualité des accueils
et la sécurité des accueils donc c'est
cette hypothèse là qui qui est à l'étude
euh le bon je peux pas vous en dire plus
parce que ça doit faire l'objet enfin
c'est c'est ce qu'a annoncé le Premier
ministre au Congrès des vers de France
d'une saisine par le gouvernement du
conseil d'administration de la CNAF et
sur cette base le conseil
d'administration de la CNAF devrait être
saisi alors finalement plutôt début
janvier d'une d'une possibilité de qui
réponde alors au aux craintes et aux
inquiétudes des maires qui par ailleurs
peuvent se comprendre c'est vrai que le
résultat aujourd'hui de de cette
segmentation en 3 heures plus
périscolaire plus extrascolaire c'est
que un établissement donné et donc
parfois la la commune doit adresser à la
TR dossiers là où pour voilà donc ça ça
crée une une charge administrative pour
les communes ça crée une charge
administrative pour nous aussi hein donc
et et puis par ailleurs c'est vrai que
s'agissant des activités périscolaires
il y a souvent même enfin la plupart du
temps continuité entre les 3 heures cons
qui sont lié à la réforme des rythmes
éducatifs et les autres d'autres
activités périscolaires
donc ce qu'il faut absolument éviter
c'est donc une dérive je vaisêtre très
claire celle que je disais tout à
l'heure et puisque nous on veut éviter
aussi parce que nous sommes liés par la
convention d'objectif et de gestion
c'est une dérive une déri financière qui
ferait que Ben d'où la nécessité de
d'être signataire des pedt voilà et puis
la dernière question c'est sur la valeur
de référence du coût horaire de
rémunération des animateurs je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est 0
alors le coût horaire c'est 4,4
€ par heure en moyenne c'est une moyenne
4,4 € par heure et la participation des
CAF est à hauteur de 0,5 € par heure et
le CEJ représente lui 1 € par
heure donc nous finançons 11 % du prix
de revien par la PSO et 23 % quand il y
a
CEJ alors par ailleurs je vous remettrai
euh on a fait bon si ça vous intéresse
je suppose la circulaire que j'ai signé
à destination des des CAF pour la mise
en œuvre de cette réforme et puis
surtout une première analyse qu'on a
faite de la réforme qui laisse quand
même entendre que globalement enfin bien
sûr c'est normal qu'une réforme de cette
taille présente un certain nombre de
difficultés mais globalement ça s'est
plutôt bien passé euh enfin sur le
terrain alors vu du point de vue des CAF
c'estàdire que nous on a une régulation
jeose pas dire administrative parce
qu'on fait plus que de l'administration
mais on a une régulation des dossiers
bon on a quand même le sentiment général
et Frédéric marinat qui est allé au
Congrès des Maires de France à l'atelier
qui était consacré au sujet c'est que
finalement pour une réforme de cette
ampleur le la mise en œuvre bon bien s
est difficile mais quand même se passe
Plô plutôt bien sur le terrain comme le
disait Jeanlou de Roussan le bon sens
prend parfois le dessus sur euh sur les
difficultés pas obligé de partager mon
optimisme
visiblement nous cherchons effectivement
beaucoup de de propositions qui nous
permettent de partager un optimisme tel
qu'il est tel qu' le vôtre monsieur
Lenoir j'aimerais vous remercier bien
évidemment d'avoir associé à à cette à
cette audition cet après-midi monsieur
dessen qui est donc président du conseil
d'administration de la de la knaf Merci
à vous également de cette contribution
il y a de nombreuses questions de la
part de mes collègues mais nous
commencerons par les questions de Madame
la rapporteur madame Cartron à laquelle
si vous en êtes d'accord vous apporterez
les réponses et ensuite nous prendrons
une série de questions après donc Madame
carton
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Directeur
euh nous
avons nous avons là au travers de votre
présentation
l'explication de ce que on a ressenti
sur le terrain puisque je vais vous
parler du ressenti du terrain euh
c'est-à-dire que les maires se sont
sentis complètement abandonnés on se
tournit vers la CAF et la CAF n'avait
pas de réponse à nous apporter entre le
mois de février et fin août et donc
alors que nous devions faire une mise en
place pour le 1er septembre aucune
indication et on nous
disait bon on réfléchit à Paris ce qui
dans une un pays où on appelle de la
DESC un peu plus de décentralisation
nous laisser beaucoup sur notre fin et
je pense que c'est une des difficultés
majeures qu'on qu'ont vécu les mares
pour la mise en place de ces rythmes
alors moi je vais essayer d'être
concrète pragmatique et de poser bon
vous avez donné des chiffres
globaux des chiffres précis c'est-à-dire
pour l'accompagnement financier des 3
heur les mis en place des rythmes c'est
combien par enfant et c'est ave quelle
contrainte posée par la CAF c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'il faut un peu DT est-ce qu'il
faut obligatoirement est-ce qu'il
faut donc des taux d'encadrement précis
est-ce qu'il faut voilà est-ce que c'est
combien par enfant est-ce que c'est lié
à des contraintes précises la parce que
aujourd'hui encore hier j'avais le
témoignage d'un des maires de Gironde
pour lesquels euh la CAF il ne comprend
plus il pense qu'il ne va pas pouvoir
prétendre à ce fond alors que c'est une
commune en plus de banlieu difficile et
qui met déjà beaucoup de choses en place
donc là première interrogation deuxème
interrogation
euh là encore ce que les mairres ne
comprennent pas et et même pour eux
c'est difficile euh vous dites que vous
avez attendu que vous attendez la sisine
du Premier ministre est-ce qu'on va
encore attendre 6 mois ou 8 mois pour
une harmonisation éventuelle des taux
d'encadrement pendant les 3 He et après
parce comment peut-on expliquer aux
parents que de 15h45 à 16h30 il y a
toute sécurité c'est parfait à 1 pour 14
et que dès qu'on REP je dis pour la
maternelle et dès qu'on passe 16h30 il
faut redescendre à 1 pour 10 c'est sur
le terrain impossible et on nattendra
pas si mot enfin je veux dire c'est pour
nous c'est non où ça va ou ça va pas
mais je bon voilà ça c'est la c'est la
deuxième question que la deuxième
question que je pose parce que pour nous
c'est compliqué après
euh je bon parce que là j'ai conscience
d'avoir tenu des propos un peu négatifs
donc je dis aussi que ça doit ça doit
dépendre de des conseillers CAF
puisque dans le territoire de la Gironde
aussi alors que j'ai était sur un hier
dans un périmètre de toute petite
commune là il y a eu un accompagnement
avec un
tableau financier fait par le conseiller
en expliquant aux communes et avec très
clairement reste à charge parce que
c'est ceux qu' on besoin de comprendre
les communes une fois les aides
possibles qu'est-ce qui reste en charge
à la collectivité pour le financement
alors je ne sais pas si ça c'est une
initiative individuelle mais je voulais
la souligner
parce que je pense que si les maires
avaient en face
d'eux ce type de de réponse et
d'accompagnement ça les aiderait à voir
plus clair alors je ne sais pas est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir même une grille mise
sur le site internet pour que chaque
maèire puisse aller calculer ce à quoi
il a droit et qu'est-ce qui lui reste à
charge parce que là encore c'est selon
et et alors ça ça contribue au climat
parce que il y en a qui vous disent mais
moi je sais ça d'autres qui disent on
m'a répondu le contraire et nous on est
on ne sait pas quoi répondre voilà donc
je pense que que que nous avons besoin
de cela euh après après bien sûr euh je
il est je ne sais pas à à quoi c'est dû
mais c'est vrai que sur le terrain on a
besoin de ce partenariat multiple
c'est-à-dire que que tout le monde se
mette autour de la table en même temps
et l'éducation nationale et la CAF et
jeunesse et sport et les parents et et
et les maires parce que là on est dans
des le maire est aujourd'hui dans des
relations qui sont duales c'est tantôt
il a à faire à l'éducation nationale
tantôt il a et ça c'est très
insécurisant voilà donc c'était les
quelques questions pardonnez-moi de
peut-être ma franchise mais j'aiessayé
de parler au nom de tous les maires
alors
d'abord je pas vous pardonner de votre
franchise on est là
pour l'audition par
Sénat et je suis là pour essayer de
répondre avec frééric bar à toutes vos
question juste une chose sur les les
délais de mise en œuvre bon je pourrais
dire que j'étais pas là
mais en la raison est simple la
convention d'objectif et de gestion a
été signée le 16 juillet moi j'ai pris
mes fonctions le 9 septembre je crois la
circulaire est partie le 27 septembre
mais il y avait eu des des des des
informations qui avaient été de toute
façon euh le Conseil la Commission
d'action sociale vous savez il y a a des
systèmes de gouvernance dans les
organismes de sécurité sociale comme il
en existe dans les mairies comme il en
existe un au niveau de l'État
et le le directeur général il est il
exécute sur ce sujet des décisions qui
sont de la compétence du conseil
d'administration c'est pour ça que j'ai
souhaité qu'on soit tous les deux
et euh bon ben il fallait que les
décisions puissent être prises sur la
placee de la cortion d'objectif et de
gestion et que la circulaire puisse
descendre rapidement et on a fait le
plus rapidement possible j'ai tout à
fait conscience que c'est pas totalement
satisfaisant pour les euh pour les élus
locaux mais en même temps c'est je crois
je vais pas revenir parce que j'étais
pas là sur la la période précédente
c'est vrai que une une concertation
mieux organisée avec l'Éducation
nationale aurait sûrement permis mais on
va pas refaire l'histoire elle s'est
écrite comme ça bon euh je je CIS
pouvoir vous dire parce que c'est la
première chose que j'ai faite en
arrivant c'est de faire cette enquête
que l'engagement de la Caisse nationale
pour faire en sorte que la réforme se
passe le mieux possible et est totale
alors pour répondre précisément à vos
questions euh l'accompagnement financier
des 3h bah il est montant de même
montant c'estàdire de la PSO c'està-dire
50 centimes d'euros par heure mais c'est
par enfant
présent hein pas par enfant inscrit je
le dis parce que et ça c'est très
clairement on y tient parce que c'est
bien par enfant présent deuxièmement
c'est pas conditionné par un peu d'été
aujourd'hui mais justement par une
déclaration c'est c'est conditionné par
une déclaration déclaration jees voilà
en revanche jeess sport jeunesse sport
desdc oui c'est le classique he c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis toujours c'est la
déclaration la fameuse déclaration
Jeunesse et Sport accueil déclaré des
dcs ou jeunesse et sport c'est le code
de l'action sociale et des familles
c'est la c'est le droit commun si vous
voulez hors expérimentation ça ça dépend
pas des règlement de c'est pas du droit
du droit knaf la knaf ne crée aucun
droitessus non parce qu'au début il y
avait cette distinction entre ce qui se
faisait d'accueil périscolaire et disant
là c'est nouveau et il y a de nouvelles
exigences c'est ce que les maires
avaient entendu oui mais il y a eu pas
mal de Quioco madame la rapporteur oui
oui je pense
c'est c'est si je peux permettre c'est
c'est un vrai sujet parce que ce que
vous dites là on devra donc interpeller
ministère deagort là-dessus parce que si
je me souviens bien enfin j'ai quelques
notes là par rapport à ça c'est ce
système de déclaration reconnue par la G
sport ça relève de six critères oui hein
don il en a un qui est contestable c'est
celui en tout auou moins ce qui me
semble interprétatif de la part de de je
sport mais ça vous concerne peêre au
moins c'est un le premier critères
situés hors du domicile parental c'est
le cas deuxième critère se déroule
pendant les vacances et les loisirs des
mineurs c'est là qu'il y a un vrai sujet
d'interprétation sur le et euh voilà
ensuite collectif au moins 7 mineurs
c'est le cas la plupart du temps à
caractère éducatif bien entendu c'est le
cas entrant dans l'une des trois
catégories avec ou sans hébergement ou
le scoutisme et cetera bon ça c'est le
cas ouvert au mineurs dès lorsque la la
réation effective voilà donc le problème
qui est posé par rapport à
l'intervention de la CAF en lien avec le
la je sport porte essentiellement sur
l'interprétation se déroule pendant les
vacances et les loisirs des mineurs
voilà c'est ce les loisir des mineurs
qui me semble être un vrai sujet mais ça
je comprends tout à fait que vous vous
caliez sur la la réglementation la G
sport nous on devra probablement
demander sur ce point précis des
explications à la JEE sport
je pense que vous parlez de laissé
frédri Mar qui connait mieux que moi je
pense que vous parlez de l'extrascolaire
là
pércol parle ce que les mes veulent
savoir c'est le financement d'étapes oui
oui voilà non mais alors 3h c'est le
financement sécurité sociale oui oui
après je sais qu'il y a le fond
d'amorçage simplement je veux dire par
en ce moment parce que bon il y a cette
ce bas entre ces ministères divers et
variés aujourd'hui on nous parle
d'accueil déclaré c'est-à-dire et
l'accueil déclaré il relève de ça
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui la Jeunesse
et Sport qui s qui doit je sais pas si
s'annu ou quoi se sont mis en tête de
nous mettre les accueils déclarés
partout dans toutes les écolle monsieur
fauconier on va peut-être laisser
monsieur LIR nous
répondre à cette question reprendre
ensuite nos questionns voilà il fera
mieux que moi de marin je vous explique
bien les différents cadres juridiques
c'està dire le périscolaire
l'extrascolaire et dans le périscolaire
les fameuses 3 heures et après on pourra
prolonger parce que en fait le problème
qui existe aujourd'hui c'est comparaison
entre ces 3 heures liées à la réforme
des rythmes éducatifs et puis le
périscolaire que nous gérions déjà avec
les normes et le décret du 2 août a
introduit une double dérogation en fait
mais je vais vous laisser une double
dérogation une première qui est pour les
3hures et une deuxième dans le cadre des
P d'été je pense que vous l' merci
Monsieur le Directeur mais je vais
essayer en tout cas depuis toujours la
knaf s'est intéressée à l'accueil péri
et extrascolaire c'estàdire le temps qui
jxte l'école alors le temps qui jxte
l'école le matin le midi pendant la
pause méridienne et le soir après la la
classe c'est du temps périscolaire on
est d'accord et la réforme des Rym
éducatif c'est sur le temps périscolaire
c'est sur ce temps-là le temps qui est
le temps du mercredi après-midi
complètement après la classe en dehors
totalement et le temps des weekends et
des vacances et petitte ou grande c'est
le temps extrascolaire pour autant on
paye la même prestation de service
ordinaire la même subvention qui est de
50 € centimes d'euros par enfant pour
autant nous distinguons bien les deux et
la la knaf est toujours attachée à ce
temps périscolaire parce que nous nous
sommes sur des fondamentaux chez nous
hein l'accueil et l'éveil de l'enfant et
la la conciliation vie familiale et vie
professionnelle donc depuis toujours
nous subventionnons par des prestations
de service qu'on appelle des prestations
des subventions si vous voulez monsieur
Loir en a parlé les
alssh les accueils des loisirs sans
hébergement qu' en terme autre et commun
lié à notre enfance peut-être mutuelle
nous appelions ensemble les centres
aérés bon voilà c de loisir les centres
de loisir donc là voilà nous payons
24000 centes de loisirs et cetera nous
nous adossons depuis toujours toujours à
la knnaf sur le droit commun le droit
commun qui est l'article
r2271 code de l'action sociale et des
familles qui est le droit commun pour le
péri et l'extrascolaire qui
h nous nous donne le droit en terme
d'encadrement des enfants moins de 6 ans
plus de 6 ans en gros hein je peux faire
je peux raffiner et qui est le droit
qu'on appelle dans notre langage
ordinaire excusez-moi le droit jeunesse
et
sport c'est pas un droit inventé par les
CAF c'est pas qu' on a souvent dit les C
invente leur droit ou non non pas du
tout on a le droit commun le décret du 2
août dont tu as parlé le directeur
général de la CAF permet une dérogation
au droits commun en assouplissant
sensiblement sensiblement les
encadrements et les nombres d'animateurs
pour les moins de 6 ans ou c'est plus il
y a un nombre d'ateur plus grand et pour
les plus de 6 ans voilà du coup nous
sommes confrontés à tout ça parce que
nous CAF nnaf n CAF nous avons notre
propre droit qui est sur l'accueil des
mineurs au sens jeess et sport on se
voit on voit arriver une nouvelle
législation dérogatoire pendant 3 ans et
nous nous nous nous y sommes adaptés
c'est-à-dire que on peut pas nous
reprocher de ne pas avoir accompagné les
3 heur parce que la réforme qui organise
la la la la semaine de classe sur 9
semaines et qui rend le mercredi matin
jour de classe libère 3h nous avons donc
décidé à la CAF de payer ces 3 heur
rendu libre par par la réforme par le
Viet par le BIA d'une aide spécifique
l'aide spécifique des 3 He qui est égale
à 54 € par
enfant hein 54 € par
enfant oui absolument si monsieurard l'a
dit présent ça voilà nous sommes
budgetés à pour pour le faire à hauteur
de 850 millions d'euros ce sont des
dépenses nouvelles dans le casadre de la
COG des dépenses nouvelles hein ce qu'a
dit Monsieur L noir c'està dire 62 € du
fond d'amorçage ça rien ne le laissait
prévoir au moment de la signature de la
CG enfin peu de temps avant on l'a
appris pas pas longtemps avant en tout
cas donc nous avons sur en dépens
nouvell sur la réforme des ritmes
éducatif 912 millions d'euros donc on
paye les 3 heures rendu libre par la
réforme au pour 54 € par enfant ça c'est
voilà en fait ça correspond au 0,50 par
heure multiplié par 3 He multipli par
les 36 semain exactement ce qu' dit
président et Monsieur mais voilà ça fait
54 € par ce que j'ai expliqué au de
francealcu ça fait
par ailleurs nous continuons à payer on
a rien on a pas rétrogradé notre
offre on continue à payer l'accueil
classique qu'on va appeler PSO classique
si vous voulez moi que je 54 € c'est la
PS spécifique PS spécifique r éducatif
PS et la PSO classique on continue à la
payer elle elle est elle est égale à 50
€ enfin elle est égale à 50 centimes
d'euros par enfant par heure voilà ça
fait une dépense très importante par an
au autour de 153 millions d'euros donc
là non on a Contin on continue à payer
les alssh pour la PSO classique pour les
autres rythmes et priscolaires qui sont
pas dans la réforme le matin le soir la
pause méridienne on continue on n pas du
tout tout du tout renoncer à tout ça
mais on prend voilà pour pour autant ce
juste ilut préciser pour ceux qui
respectent qui respectter les normes
d'encadrement voilà voilà pour pour
autant on est dans l'accueil des parce a
parfois une incompréhension on veut
rester dans le droit commun là-dessus
hein et ce que les mairies peuvent
parfois discuter avec nous où il y a un
enjeu disputé là-dessus c'est justement
que certaines mairies ont sont passés en
en norme allégé pour une partie de la
PSO classique de ces heures voilà pour
autant nous on dit qu' on accompagne que
la réforme on peut on ne peut pas tout
accompagner je sais pas si je suis clair
je peut-être pas très clair si
excusez-moi si je suis pas très clair on
accompagne que les 3
heures une Marie qui basculerait tout
tout tout toutes ces heures
périscolaires en en accueil à léger nous
ne pouvons pas l'accompagner on
accompagne que ce qui est dû par la
réforme point point on accompagne la
réforme mais pour uniquement ces 3
heures pardonnez-moi si je puis me
permettre la question fondamentale est
là oui comment est-ce que le maire peut
justifier qu'à un moment donné sur 1
heure l'encadrement est allégé peut-être
avec les mêmes animateurs et ensuite ils
sont pris en charge dans le périscolaire
mais avec un taux d'encadrement plus
élevé comment peut-on justifier cela
est-ce que vous êtes dans une démarche
d'allègement globale ou pas attendez
justement c'était la suite de la
question de madame on à cette là juste
une petite question il y a des maires
qui me disent que il se trouent avec une
augmentation oui de de l'accueil en
périscolaire en périscolaire et on leur
dit la CAF dit qu'elle ne prend pas en
charge
l'augmentationadame et et je continue
non mais je vous rapporte après c'est
peutêtre pas vraii je comprends bien et
deuxième chose il y a des mares qui
n'avaient pas de périscolaire et qui le
créent parce que tout se crée
répondre attz excusez-moi juste un point
de parce qu'on a une autre
audition à 45 d'accord donc
éventuellement ce que je ferai c'est que
je continuerai et
puis voilà sur l'autre audition qui est
sur la médiation c'est un sujet qui
voilà dans le cadre de la loi famille
bon
donc donc si jamais il y a des questions
très précises auquell les élus attendent
pour ça que j'ai souhaité qu'on puisse
voilà donc nous vous écoutons
attentivement alors d'abord pour la je
pense que le cadre je pense que il est
clair le cadre tel qu'il a été fixé et
mis en œuvre par les CAF c'est celui qui
a décrit frédériic marin c'estàd
qu'effectivement il y a une dualité qui
a été qui est résultat de la réforme et
de l'allègement qui a été introduit
enfin de la dérogation qui a été
introduite par le décret du 2 août à
titre expérimental et qui effectivement
crée une distorsion et je moi je
comprends tout à fait enfin le conseil
d'administration aussi d'ailleurs que ça
ça que ça crée un trouble chez les élus
chez les maires parce qu'effectivement
il y avait une continuité de l'activité
avait d'un seul coup une rupture en H
terme d'encadrement ça n'est que le
résultat de cette dérogation alors il y
a une deuxième possibilité de dérogation
qui a été introduite par le décret du 2
août et les discussions aujourd'hui
porte là-dessus c'est la possibilité
d'assouplir alors pour les heures qui ne
sont pas du périscolaire associé à la à
la réforme des rythmes éducatifs dans le
cadre d'un pedt et de toute façon enfin
je l'ai dit au président de la MF dès
que je l'ai vu nous nous ne pouvons pas
parce que la la loi et le décret c'est
comme si c'était la loi s'applique à
tout le monde nous ne pouvons pas
déroger autrement que dans ce cadre-là
puisque les les normes d'accompagnement
des activités périscolaire dit classique
la PSO habituelle c'est c'est sur les
normes donc on peut avoir voir cette
cette possibilité c'est ce que nous
étudions aujourd'hui dans le dans le
groupe de travail dont dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure et c'est ce qui quand les
travaux auront aboutis sera soumis au
conseil d'administration de l'ctaf alors
vous me disiez pardonnez-moi Monsieur le
Directeur Général concrètement j'ai un
péri scolaire oui si je si je conçois un
un un projet éducatif et que j'inclus
mon périscolaire qui existe depuis
longtemps dans ce projet éducatif je
peux alléger le taux encadrement sur
l'ensemble du dispositif ou pas non
aujourd'hui non mais vous êtes en train
de travailler dans ce sensl essay de
trouver une solution en utilisant cette
voie mais pour l'instant
non
ahord j'ai moins de personnel à
payer le pedt ENF d'abord le règlement
mais surtout c'est un moyen de vérifier
que la diminution du taux d'encadrement
ne se traduit pas par une dégradation du
caractère
éducatif comprend effectivement
l'attention de la de la CAF à ne pas
avoir une dégradation de l'encadrement
sur le périscolaire parce que
effectivement même si ça fait moins de
personnel à payer par les mares c'est
quand même pas le même cadre que sur
l'école les 3 heures elles sont sur le
l'école elles sont dans un local
scolaire avec des règles des rythmes
enfin des règlements qui peuvent être
étendus et entre une classe de 25 élèves
et un groupe de 18 bon on peut penser
que ça va mais dès l'instant qu'on passe
au au au périscolaire où là on est dans
un autre type d'encadrement avec des
projets qui se construisent avec les
enfants dans une plus grande liberté
c'est vrai que l'inquiétude que vous
avez de d'une dégradation de
l'encadrement il y a un certain nombre
de d'élus de responsables de centre de
loisirs qui qui qui la partage donc ce
que la question que je vous pose c'est
en quoi la signature d'un pedt qui
intégrerait le les les les activités du
rythme scolaire et le péiscolaire aurait
une apporterait une garantieop bien
qu'il y a une continuité entre les deux
activités c'est ça l'objet du
pedt c'est ce qui est prévu par le Pr le
décret le Pdt le Pdt n'est pas opposable
à la CAF le Pdt concerne la LSH et la
structure l'organisme la commune voilà
vous ne pouvez pas déroger sans pedt
pour autant nous ce qui nous importe le
Pdt n'est pas une pièce justificative
pour nous ça ça vraiment alors là
vraiment ce qui est comme nous les
pièces justificatives pour payer
excusez-moi à la fin c'est au final le
point d'application c'est bien le
paiement donc c'est la déclaration
Jeunesse et Sport l'accueil déclarer
c'est pour nous c'est ça c'est la
déclaration point barre et puis le
nombre d'heures des gamins voilà voilà
hein voilà c'est tout donc le Pdt c'est
simplement le support prévu par le code
de l'action sociale et des familles ou
est prévu par la par le décret du 2 août
qui permet à
l'expérimentation voilà c'est tout ouais
pour les 3h pour les 3h je crois qu'on
va je crois qu'on va prendre toutes les
oui non pardon madame la Présidente le
le les incidences sur les augmentations
d'effectifs
ou les créations là de de dans les
accueils de loisirs parce qu'il y a des
maires qui ont reçu ou ont eu des avis
négatifs de la part de la CAF lorsqu'ils
sollicitent lorsqu'ils avaient plus
d'enfants désormais à
accueillir voilà donc la réponse qui
leur a été donnée c'était non on y va
pas sur ça puisqu'on va sur on va
essentiellement sur l'étape alors est-ce
que ça c'est une réalité pas c'était pas
en fonction du nombre d'enfants madame
je ne pense pas du tout fonction de du
Tau d'encadrement c'est en fonction
simplement du T voilà c'est c'est pas du
tout le nombre enfant n'a rien à voir
hein pour nous nous on n pas on a on on
n pas notre propre droit du guichet
comme on dit hein vraiment là je
voudrais que que que que ce soit très
clair on a on a le droit du code de
l'action sociale et des familles et on
va dans l'expérimentation résolument
résolument qu'on n'est pas du
tout on le dit partout simplement avec
notre propre notre propre action sociale
hein on est sur l'action sociale quand
même c'est pas les prestations légales
et et et et avec nos propres normes qui
sont celles jeuness et sport donc on
accompagne la réforme pour les 3hur on
accompagne le droit classique avec les
la PSO classique pour tous les et les
sages on a renoncé on honore nos
contrats on on surveille de dépens parce
que pour nous c'est une dépense à
comportement imprévisible on préfère
vous le dire on le dit comme ça on est
très très sensible à toute évolution de
la dépense parce que cette dépense et
fonction du comportement d'acteur le
taux de recours des parents le la
richesse des formules proposées aux
enfants et aux parents le taux de
recours la question des transports
scolaires la question du recrutement des
animateurs il y a il y a 10 15 20
questions qui se posent pour évaluer
l'augmentation de la dépense donc on en
est à ce droit positif là cons COG le
directeur général de Lana vous a dit que
nous nous nous allons résolument nous
orienter vers les propositions du
Premier ministre qui nous demande de
mettre en place une expérimentation dans
le cadre de premier semestre 2014 pour
voir comment on peut s eng ager plus
avant vers des normes assouplies prises
en charge par la CAF nous allons le
faire et on est là-dessus et j'étais au
Congrès des Maires de France mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je sais pas si
vous y étiez également vous avez dû me
voir
bon j'ai retenu l'idée que nous avenions
tous en marchant tous en marchant sur
cette réforme c'est c'est c'est c'est
pas c'est pas du dogmatisme c'est du
pragmatisme laacnaf est également dans
ce pragmatisme si alors si vous voulaz
juste un mot en terme de méthode par
rapport à question de calendrier euh
c'est la raison pour laquelle d d dès
mon arrivée j'ai fait une j'ai voulu
qu'on fasse une enquête parce que
évidemment la première année c'est une
année un peu test bon c'est bon donc on
a fait cette enquête sur la base de
cette enquête on avait prévu de toute
façon d'avoir des échanges avec laamf il
se trouve que entre-temps ces échanges
se sont fait sous sous l'égide du
gouvernement pour justement voir comment
peut tester alors dès le début de
l'année prochaine c'est pour pour
répondre à votre question dès le début
de l'année prochaine un assouplissement
mais dans le cadre prévu par la loi et
de façon avec deux objectifs pour être
clair le premier c'est de garantir quand
même une qualité de la de l'accueil en
terme à la fois éducatif mais aussi de
sécurité il faut pas oublier cette
question de sécurité et je crois que
vous receviez juste avant l'UNAF qui est
conseil d'administration de la Caf les
délégations du conseil d'administration
de la Caf et l'UNAF en particulier mais
les autres aussi sont particulièrement
soucieuses de de de de de cette question
de sécurité donc garantir la sécurité et
puis il faut le dire aussi Dee façon à
éviter une une dérive financière qui
ferait
que notre notre enveloppe prévue dans la
COG serait trop dépassé par exemple une
des craintes que nous avons on n' pas
j'ai pas encore les remontées
financières mais c'est que par rapport à
l'enveloppe qui avait été prévu en 2013
elle soit dépassée parce que le taux de
recours des parents pour des raisons
divers peut-être lié par exemple à la
crise et qui font que d'autres types de
d'accueil n'ont pas lieu le tau de
recours serait supérieur à ce que nous
avions anticipé par exemple donc nous
avons besoin aussi comme disait Frédéric
marinac le mouvement se prouve marchant
et on marche dans la même direction nous
avons besoin de pouvoir comment dire
ajuster le tir de façon à respecter ces
deux exigences qui sont à la fois de
qualité mais aussi de respect des
enveloppes financières merci Monsieur le
Directeur Général j'ai j'ai quatre
questions je souhaiterais qu'elles soi
brève pour que nous puissions avoir des
réponses BRV non non des réponses très
très claires il nous reste 10 minutes
donc Monsieur Martin madame duchen
monsieur fauconniier et Monsieur le
squarnek s'il vous plaît merci madame la
Présidente j'espère avoir compris tout
ce que vous avez expliqué ça je m'y
efforce à tout le moins mais si vous
voulez vous vous êtes trouvé enrôlé dans
une opération
que vous ne pensiez pas devoir
participer bien cela suscite de votre
part des financements est-ce que à
partir de là votre propre politique qui
existe toujours pourra être conduite à
son terme c'est un une première question
deuxièmement le taux d'encadrement le
taux d'encadrement finalement vous avez
trouvé des mesures
dérogatoires ces mesures dérogatoires
seront quand même pour les moins de 6
ans et pour les plus de 6 ans j'espère
des deux côtés
mais alors comment fera-t-on comprendre
dans nos communes que bien entendu entre
les C les sach et le P périscolaire le
taux d'encadrement ne sera pas le même
peut-être pour des âges identiques ce ne
sera pas certainement facile à imaginer
et enfin personnellement j'avais misise
en place dans ma commune depuis 1995
c'était en quelque sorte des rythmes
scolaires c'était volontairement nous le
faisions et puis est arrivé un moment où
évidemment au niveau de la CAF nous
avons dû négocier nous n'avons jamais
trouvé de solution la CAF m'a dit bah ça
dépend de la knaf la knaf vous dira quoi
oui écoutez je n'ai jamais eu de réponse
de la CAF ni de la CAF résultat on a
abandonné à l'époque hein voilà euh les
questions que je pose mais je dois dire
que dans cet
umbrogliot nous avons du mal à nous y
retrouver
sincèrement madame du oui ma question
était essentiellement celle dont on
parlait la présidente et la rapporteur
mais du coup j'ai eu une idée
entre-temps on parle du coup beaucoup de
Jeunesse et Sport hein ça a l'air
fondamental dans tout le raisonnement
que vous nous avez
expliqué les 3 heur qui vienne de
l'enseignement qui vienne du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale est-ce que vous
êtes obligé pour ces 3 He de passer par
la jeunesse les
sports pour faire le décompte et cetera
voilà très bien Madame duchen Monsieur
fauconier
simplement position de de collègues de
la canaf qui participent à mon comité de
pilotage qui sont restés tétanisés
pendant quasiment des mois parce que si
j'ai bien compris ce que vous avez dit
c'est vous qui avez sollicité
l'éducation nationale pour savoir ce que
vous serez susceptible de faire voilà
ben mais vous le confirmer donc bon ça
me ça don quand même sur la la mécanique
bon c'est pas c'est pas un reproche que
je fais à vous bien entendu hein donc
moi je je voudrais poser une question
année là aujourd'hui on voit bien que
c'est pas simple mais euh c'est surtout
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la suite des
événements moi je pense qu'est-ce que
enfin tout au moins qu'est-ce que vous
pensez aujourd'hui on doit faire un PDD
un PDD c'est en fait euh l'initiative
d'éducation nationale c'est leur
problème hein c'est un espèce de c'est
très intéressant à faire mais ce qui
antérieurement comme Monsieur tout à
l'heure le disait comme moi-même on a
déjà des conventions avec la CAF contrat
jeunesse et cetera et cetera contrat
famille hein est-ce qu'on peut pas
imaginer que maintenant
on met les choses un peu à plat on fait
en sorte que le contrat éducatif de
territoire enfin appelonsle comme on
voudreit on peut changer pour pas
blesser et la jeunesse et sport et la
CAF à rapport à l'éducation nationale on
lui donne un autre nom et qu'au bout
d'un moment on arrête ce cinéma et on
fasse en sorte que la Jeunesse et des
Sports vous l'éducation nationale les
maires bien entendu l'association
cémaire construise un système cohérent
et qu'on soit pas dans cette situation
un peu délicate ça m'amène à dire que
aujourd'hui ce qu'on me dit moi dans mon
département alors que j'ai mis en place
un r scolaire on me dit attention alors
qu'on a des contrats déjà conventionnés
avec vous il y a aucun problème depuis
des années tout se passe très bien on
mais dit attention maintenant pour qu'on
puisse payer les 3 He les 3 He
puisqu'ils sont dérogatoires il faudra
faire un accueil déclaré accueil qu'on a
déjà puisquon a on a un CS hein voilà
donc il faudra faire faire un accueil
déclaré l'accueil déclaré c'est les six
critères que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
c'est ceux qu'ils disent d'ailleurs aux
maires qui ont pas commencé et je
comprend que ça les rend fou parce
qu'ils disent attendez six critères mais
moi c'est une histoire de fou hein si on
ajoute à ça ce que j'ai pas dit c'est
que l'accueil déclaré il y a des
contraintes quand même administratives
au passage en particulier il faut un
directeur diplômé et cetera bien hein
donc est-ce qu'on peut qu'est-ce que
vous pensez d'une d'un système qui
consisterait à ce que vous met
tous les trois dans un dispositif clair
précis avec un seul critère je comprends
que ça sera difficile quand même ce que
disait mon collègue de revenir
aujourd'hui on a dérogé à une règle hein
ça sera compliqué de revenir à la
dérogation en disant maintenant non non
après c'est on revient comme avant
c'està-dire à 14 ou à 10 donc voilà il
faut on a besoin de ce mais ça ça ça
interpelle beaucoup plus la jeunesse et
sport que vous hein ça c'est
clair donc donc une dernière question
monsieur le squarnc s'il vous plaît oui
merci Mame la présidente juste très
rapide donc euh je vois que la knaf va
devoir dépenser apporter des sommes donc
il était pas prévu euh ceci veut-il dire
que pour les crèches les pôles
multi-accueil les financements euh
autres pour les vacances et tout vont
être réduits pour trouver cet argent
parce qu'il y a des conventions euh au
niveau des communes avec les départ
enfin c départemental et cetera est-ce
qu'il y aura encore une baisse des
dotations parce que souvent les communes
se sont engagé dans les réalisations en
investissement également des aides pour
le fonctionnement et donc il faudra
savoir dans le coût dans le coût de
l'opération parce que s'il y a des
réductions ça fait partie du du coût des
réformes des savoir la vérité combien
que ça coûte si on nous enlève par
ailleurs euh c'est c'est comme si on n
donnait pas peut-être répondre à de voix
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet la convention
d'objectif et de gestion est très claire
il y a la répartition des financements
et de en en deux mots ce qui est quand
même assez considérable euh le FNAS le
Fond national d'action sociale sur la
durée de la COG augmente de 2 milliards
d'euros voir un peu plus et passe de 4,6
milliards à 6,6 milliards c'est quand
même un effort important et la plus
grosse partie euh n'est pas destinée à
l'accompagnement des rythmes scolaires
mais la plus grosse partie est liée euh
notamment au développement des
dispositifs d'accueil de la petite
enfance euh bah et et notamment au
rééquilibrage territorial puisqu'il y a
de gros idquité territoriale et est
consacré aussi au développement de la
médiation et plus généralement des
dispositifs d'accompagnement de la
parentalité c'est le sujet sur lequel
nous avons une autre audition euh de la
médiation et et si j'ai insisté tout à
l'heure sur la nécessité du pilotage
financier c'est que effectivement il
faudrait pas parce que comme c'est la
dépense Frédéric marinach l'a dit la
dépense n'est pas totalement prévisible
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'elle soit
pilotée et il faudrait pas que il y ait
des dérives par expliquez-moi
l'expression financière sur ce sujet
c'est pour ça que nous sommes soucieux
non seulement des questions de qualité
mais aussi des questions de c'est une
discussion que nous avons avec la MF de
dérives financière parce que ça irait au
détriment d'autres politiques publiques
qui sont au moins aussi importantes et
pour ce qui concerne l'accueil de la
petite enfance je crois pour les élus
locaux très importantes donc donc ça
enfin moi je pense que làdessus ça voilà
et je peux vous dire que le conseil
d'administration est particulièrement
vigilant sur ce sujet depuis que je suis
arrivé je crois qu'à chaque réunion du
conseiladministration
voilà les administrateurs me rappellent
que il faut qu'il a un pilotage
budgétaire sur ce sujet c'est pour ça
que j'insiste toujours sur nécessité de
piloter alors deuxièmement sur ce que
vous disiez d'avoir je CIS toutes les
questions ce qu'on veut expérimenter
justement c'est ce serait un seul
dispositif qui souscouvert mais on va
l'expérimenter pour voir si on peut
généraliser sans dériv financière c'est
un peu la quadrature du cercle mais il y
a que les sujets qu'on aborde pas qu'on
est sûr de jamais régler hein donc c'est
trouver l'équation qui permette d'avoir
ce que vous disiez alors l'exérimenter
sur le 1emier semestre 2014 avec les les
communes qui sont rentrées dans la
réforme pour voir si on peut le
généraliser mais probablement à titre
expérimental pour la rentrée et si c'est
pas pour la rentrée au moins parce que
ça fait partie aussi de objectifs qui
sont des objectifs de simplification
parce que ce qui est lourd pour les élus
locaux que vous
je sais que le Sénat est aussi le Grand
Conseil des communes de France le ce qui
est lourd pour les élus locaux que vous
êtes est également lourd pour les
caisses en terme de gestion ce qui peut
d'ailleurs expliquer les les petites
enfin les difficultés plus ou moins
importantes que vous avez pu rencontrer
avec vos caisses je crois enfin et c'est
aussi c'est un des sujets que nous
essayons c'est de faire en sorte qu'il a
un pilotage par la Caisse nationale de
la réforme de façon à ce que les caisses
se mettent en en ordre de marche en
ordre de bataille excusez-moi ce terme
de façon à pouvoir à la rentrée
prochaine apporter un un un appui de
meilleure qualité probablement alors
fort heureusement la réforme na concern
que 20 % des effectifs ce qui nous
permet d'avoir les effets d'expérience
de ces 20 priers % et merci à tous ceux
qui sont engagés dès cette première
année parce que bon c'est c'est ça
s'appelle engage populaire essuyer les
plâtres mais quand on construit une
nouvelle maison il y a toujours des
plâtres à essuyer donc c'est c'est ce
que nous nous avons essayé de faire le
mieux possible d'où d'où l'enquête dont
je vous remettrai les premiers résultats
et et dernier point j'ai j'ai entendu
les questions sur on sait pas ce que
veut la knaf alors première chose depuis
depuis que je suis là maintenant les
c'est les circulaires euh concernant
enfin toutes les circulaires de la knaf
ne sont pas publié mais les circulaires
de cette nature notamment celles sur les
rythme scolaire sont publié euh c'est
sur caf.fr c'est alors la décision je
l'ai prise en arrivant mais est
effective de depuis la semaine dernière
donc si vous allez sur caf.fr vous
trouverez la circulaire de la knaf
concernant la mise en œuvre des rythmes
scolaires et ça sera désormais publié de
telle sorte qu'il y a au moins une
transparence vis-à-vis des tiers de des
des instructions qui sont données par
laacnap je P que ça relève aussi de
l'administration moderne que de faire en
sorte qu'il y a une transparence c'est
souci souci qui est participé partagé
par tous nos concitoyens par les élus
nous n'avons pas encore alors s'il y a
des questions on répond au courrier qui
nous a adressé on essaye du moins nous
n'avons pas encore mis en place mais
j'ai ça fait partie des des sujets un
dispositif qui permettrait d'accéder
alors peut-être pas par un site mais au
moins par une lettre une lettre au
commune de avoir une information plus
ciblée sur les conditions de mise en
œuvre de façon à ce qu'il a pas de de
difficultés qui est pas les difficultés
de compréhension tout à fait normal que
que vous avez enfin que vous avez
rencontré dans l'interprétation des
textes on a une sédimentation de texte
qui est difficile et bon évidemment la
compréhension même par nos par nos
caisses par les les conseillers des
caisses ça a été quelque chose d' d'un
peu complexe la répercussion donc je on
fait en sorte je veux pas dire je
m'engage parce que ça dépend de de
l'ensemble du réseau et des 30000
collaborateurs on fait en sorte que la
rentrée prochaine se passe dans de
meilleures conditions et en tenant
compte des des des Acquis de
l'Expérience bon et puis effectivement
d'expérimenter un dispositif qui
permettrait d'éviter cette rupture alors
qui a été mise en place je peux pas dire
pourquoi mais qui effectivement qui
conduit à ce que pour des activités
identiques en fait on est deux dossiers
à à remplir je comprends que ça soit
troublant pour pour les les élus et
c'est aussi troublant pour nous bon en
même temps la première année a été faite
comme ça donc on va essayer et de le
faire pour répondre à votre question on
va pas attendre 6 mois en tout cas pour
l'expérimenter bien monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
Madame Monsieur Merci de votre
contribution si vous en êtes d'accord je
pense qu'il serait souhaitable qu'on
puisse revoir peut-être à l'issue de des
des conclusions de votre groupe de
travail que vous formez avec avec
Matignon pour voir un petit peu vers
quoi on se dirige et sans doute il y
aura-t-il encore quelques
questionnements d'ici là donc si vous
êtes d'accord on vous conviera pour une
nouvelle audition un petit peu plus
tard merci la circulaire les éléments de
l'enquête et puis j'ai oublié de le dire
tout à l'heure le guide pratique qui a
été adressé sous couvert de l'éducation
nationale et la classe nationale à tous
les élus sur la mise en
uvre des activités scolaires vous avez
les 80 questions que vous
posez ou et en plus il y a les réponses
si c'était possible que vous l'envoyez
directement dans les mairie plutôt que
de passer par l'Éducation nationale ça
serait peut-être une bonne chose on
serait plus sûr de la voir visiblement
on a peut-être encore quelques progrès à
Monsieur directeur général il a un
problème d'acheminement de votre
document jusque dans les mes il est
accessible sur le site ou il est sur le
site C cf.com et euh et c'est mieux en
terme de développement
durable vous le permettez il serait oui
il serait sans doute opportun d'en
parler à l'Association des maires de
France pour qu'elle fasse un message à
tous les maires de de de France pour
qu'il télécharge ce document parce que
on est plusieurs autour de cette table à
être des maires et nous ne l'avons pas
reçu en
mairie voilà vous avez donc pu voir deux
auditions menées par la mission commune
d'information sur les rythmes scolaires
d'abord l'Union nationale des
associations familiales puis et bien le
directeur général de la Caisse nationale
d'allocation familiale vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire et bien cet
après-midi à
16h30 pour le projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2013 24h Sénat avec
Delphine Girard très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires